So eine Melodie dürfte hinlänglich bekannt sein. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt Zeit fürs Chaos Radio auf Fritz, heute Teil 137. Chaos Radio für die, die zum ersten Mal einschalten, ist eine Sendung von und mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Hier geht es um Themen, die jeden Einzelnen von euch und uns betreffen, egal ob man das im ersten Moment realisieren mag oder nicht. Es geht hier um Firmen, die über Kundenkarten eure Daten sammeln und dann damit Schindluder treiben wollen, die zum Beispiel weitergeben an Leute, wo es ihr gar nicht wollt. Es geht hier um Leute, die Politik machen, die uns zum Beispiel per elektronischem Ausweis oder Krankenkarte uns da irgendwie kategorisieren, katalogisieren und auch Dinge über uns sammeln, von denen wir das gar nicht wissen wollen. Und es geht damit auch um die Unsicherheit der Daten, die von euch gesammelt werden. Damit sind wir nämlich beim Thema der heutigen Sendung. Daten, die von euch irgendwo liegen, die zum Beispiel auf irgendeinem Server liegen oder irgendeinem Rechner, da wollen wir doch alle, dass die sicher und gut und trocken verwahrt sind. Das muss ausprobiert werden von Leuten, die sich genau darum kümmern, um zu gucken, ob diese Daten sicher sind. Und um das zu gewährleisten, müssen diese Computersysteme oder diese Sicherheitssysteme immer wieder gecheckt werden. Und das ist in Deutschland mittlerweile strafbar. Es gibt nämlich Paragraph 202c, Strafgesetzbuch, der sagt, wenn eine Straftat vorbereitet, indem man Passwörter, Sicherheitscodes oder Computerprogramme herstellt oder zugänglich macht, wird mit bis zu einem Jahr Knast- oder Geldstrafe belangt. Das ist zusammengefasst der sogenannte Hackerparagraph. Und dem geht es heute hier im Chaosradio, Teil 137. Und Konz ist hier und Felix ist auch hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Hallo, ihr beiden. Wo ist das Problem bei diesem Hackerparagraphen?
Na, es gibt mehrere Probleme. Also, wir sind ja Hacker und wir führen uns direkt Betroffene durch. Denn wir haben unter anderem diese Tools, um die es in den Paragraphen geht. Und wir wollen damit nicht unbedingt jemanden angreifen, sondern wir finden, man braucht die auch aus anderen Gründen. Aber das Gesetz hat so ein bisschen Schwierigkeit, ein Hackertool zu definieren. Deswegen haben sie es sich versucht leicht zu machen und gesagt, ein Tool mit dem Zweck, andere Leute anzugreifen, ist ein Hackertool. Und es ist aber gar nicht so einfach zu sagen, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellt. Das heißt, auch ein Tool, was ich gar nicht als Angriffstool benutzen möchte. Selbst ein Tool, das überhaupt nicht angreifen kann, sollte man denken. Also, wovon ich gar nicht weiß, dass man es zum Angreifen benutzen kann. Was ja bei vielen Leuten wahrscheinlich ist, die von Computern nicht viel Ahnung haben. Die installieren sich halt irgendwas aus dem Netz und wissen gar nicht, dass man es als Hackertool interpretieren kann. Also praktisch die Definition eines Hackertools geht darüber, dass man sagt, es hat den Zweck, damit jemanden anzugreifen. Und der Besitz von einem solchen Tool ist strafbar, selbst wenn ich überhaupt keinen angegriffen habe. Und selbst wenn ich es gar nicht wollte. Also die Intention soll zwar nachgewiesen werden, aber das Gesetz macht sich da auch einfach und sagt, wenn jemand ein Tool hat, mit dem man das tun kann, dann ist klar. Also wenn das Tool den Zweck hat, das zu tun, dann ist klar, der wollte auch angreifen und die Intention ist quasi auf dem Beifahrer sind es mitgekommen.
Wir haben hier eine ganz interessante Situation, denn es gibt dieses Gesetz, das ist Rechtsgrundlage in Deutschland und alle, aber wirklich Experten und auch Programmierer und Hacker und alle Leute, die sich irgendwie damit beschäftigen, alle Leute sind gegen dieses Gesetz.
Ja, das ist also ein ziemlich langer Prozess, wie man ja so kennt, dass eben ein Gesetz zustande kommt und dieses hier ist ja bereits am 11. August im letzten Jahr in Kraft getreten und es gab halt vorher diverse Anhörungen, insbesondere zwei größere Anhörungen im Rechtsausschuss des Bundestages und da sind halt immer verschiedene Experten geladen, im Juristen, dann die Industrieverbände und unter anderem auch wir als Hacker. Ja und überraschenderweise waren sich diesmal alle einig. Alle haben also gesagt, aus verschiedenen Gründen, übrigens, ja, dieses Gesetz kann so nicht durchgehen, dann gab es eben die zweite Anhörung, da haben dann nochmal alle Experten gesagt und im Bundestag hat man trotzdem die Parlamentarier ihre Hand gehoben und so ist das Gesetz trotzdem gekommen.
Obwohl alle Experten sagen, dieses Gesetz ist Homebook.
Genau, also das gibt es schon häufiger, dass die meisten Experten sagen, ein Gesetz ist Homebook, weil dann natürlich die Lobbyverbände die Leute hinschicken, die auch sich betroffen fühlen und die fühlen sich auch meistens betroffen als negativ betroffen. Das heißt, das ist schon durchaus normal, dass die Mehrzahl der Leute, die zu solchen Anhörungen kommen, dagegen ist, aber dass das BSI, was die staatliche Behörde ist, die für Computersicherheit zuständig ist, dass die da jemanden hinschicken, die eigentlich auf der Gegenseite sind, und der ist auch dagegen, das ist so relativ selten. Also da habe ich noch nie von gehört, dass das gerade so gesetzt wird.
Das ist wirklich sehr selten. Juristen haben meistens ganz andere Argumente als die Industrie oder eben so eine Gruppierung wie der CCC als Hacker jetzt. Und dann eben noch eine staatliche Behörde, dass die sich alle einig sind, war schon selten.
Also ihre eigenen Experten haben ihnen bei ihrer Anhörung gesagt, das Gesetz ist schlecht.
Ist das BSI, also quasi auch als Bundesbehörde, schon mal dann irgendwie durchleuchtet und verklagt worden?
Es ist ein Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Also quasi die Experten, die die Regierung hat in Bezug auf IT-Sicherheit.
Also um es als Bild zu machen, die, die dafür zuständig sind, dass Frau Merkel morgens in Ruhe aufstehen stehen kann, weil sie weiß, dass keiner auf ihrem Rechner war nachts. Genau.
Und das lustige ist, also das BSI in seiner Aufgabenerfüllung verteilt auch CDs mit Hacker-Tools drauf. Und das machen sie schon, machen sie schon länger. Und deswegen gibt es jetzt eine Klage gegen das BSI von dem Tech-Channel, das ist ein Verlag mit einer Internet-Webseite. Die haben also das BSI verklagt, deswegen um mal Klarheit zu bringen in das Gesetz. Und die Klage läuft jetzt vor sich hin. Das Problem ist halt, wenn der Richter so einen Fall vor sich hat und weiß, das Verfassungsgericht wird er sich da demnächst zu äußern, ob es jetzt überhaupt stehen bleibt oder nicht, dann ist er auch nicht in Eile, das zu verhandeln. Deswegen gibt es jetzt zwar Verfahren zu dem Hacker-Paragraphen, aber es gibt noch keine Urteile.
Okay, also jetzt geht es zwischen den Bundesbehörden, dem BSI und dem Bundesverfassungsgericht immer hin und her. Die Experten sagen, wir finden das alles nicht gut. Mich persönlich, also Jakob Kranz zum Beispiel, betrifft mich das? Oder Peter Müller oder wem auch immer. Also, ich könnte jetzt auch sagen, gut irgendeine Bundesgeschichte, ich hacke ja nicht.
Also, ob er dich so direkt betrifft, müsste man natürlich im Einzelnen sehen, aber es betrifft dich in jedem Fall auf einer gewissen Ebene, denn dein Leben hängt natürlich auch von der Sicherheit von Computersystemen ab, in vieler Hinsicht, da ja alle Bereiche des Lebens mittlerweile irgendwie in gewisser Weise mit der Computerisierung zusammenhängen. Man könnte jetzt Online-Banking nehmen oder so. Du möchtest natürlich irgendwie, dass du sicher Überweisungen machen kannst. Das könnte man zählen. Du bist natürlich insofern auch betroffen. Klar.
Hat sich im Zuge des Gesetzes, das gibt es seit letztes Jahr August, also jetzt seit einem Jahr, hat sich im Zuge dessen irgendwas verändert in Deutschland? Also gibt es irgendwelche Dinge nicht mehr, die es vorher gab? Sind Firmen, die sich um Netzwerksicherheit oder so kümmern, sind die ins Ausland abgewandert, sind da Arbeitsplätze verloren gegangen? Wird eine ganze Branche bedroht?
Ja, also die Branche fühlt sich bedroht. Ich selbst betreibe eine Firma, die Computersicherheit macht, Netzwerksicherheit. Und wir sind jetzt noch nicht weggezogen, aber wir können durchaus sehen, dass uns das in der Arbeit behindert. Und interessanterweise ist das auch eine der Sachen, die Leute interessiert hat. Das ist natürlich eine Sache, die das gesetzverfassungswidrig machen würde, wenn die freie Berufsauswahl dadurch eingeschränkt wird. Und daher ist das auch eine Sache, die das Verfassungsgericht von uns wissen wollte.
Das ist gerade der Grund, warum wir uns aktuell mit diesem Hacker Paragraph befassen. In der CCC ist um eine Stellungnahme gebeten worden seitens des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes, weil da liegt eine Verfassungsbeschwerde an. Und in dieser Beschwerde geht es auch gerade um die Berufsfreiheit. Da hat ein Geschäftsführer von so einem IT-Sicherheitsunternehmen diese Beschwerde eingelegt. Und wir haben anhand des Fragenkataloges schon gesehen, dass das Gericht sich da doch recht kritisch zu diesen Paragraphen stellt. Und wir haben für alle, die gerne nachlesen möchten, natürlich diese Stellungnahme öffentlich gemacht. Die kann man unter ccc.de auch finden, denn wir wollten die allgemeinverständlich schreiben und die auch zur Verfügung stellen der Öffentlichkeit, weil wir schreiben mit der nämlich nur zu sagen, für die Schubladen.
Bedeutet dieses Gesetz dann auch, dass die Anti-Viren-Software, die ich auf meinem Rechner habe, möglicherweise gar nicht mehr aktuell ist, weil gar nicht mehr an der Erforschung der Viren geforscht werden kann, weil es ja verboten ist?
Also das ist die Sache, die wir generell herauszuarbeiten versucht haben und die wir auch in dieser Sendung versuchen werden, rauszuarbeiten. Also wenn man das Gesetz beim Wortlaut nimmt, dann ist ein Virus oder ein Wurm ein klarer Fall von einer Schadsoftware. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, eine Software, die den Zweck hat, andere Leute anzugreifen, dann ist ein Virus ganz klar betroffen. Und dann könnte man quasi sagen, der Besitz eines Virus ist verboten. Nun hat das Gesetz ein Strafgesetzbuch, das heißt, da muss auch eine Intention nachgewiesen werden. Und das könnte vielleicht an der Stelle dann schwierig werden, das nachzuweisen. Das ist auch eine Sache, die uns häufig von Juristen gesagt wird, die sagen, ach, ihr macht euch da viel zu viel Sorgen. Die Intention wäre ja gar nicht nachweisbar. Zum Beispiel in dem Fall mit dem Virus, wahrscheinlich wirklich schwierig. Aber vom Wortlaut des Gesetzes her ist der Besitz eines Virus verboten. Und das heißt unter anderem, dass ein Antivirenhersteller den Virus nicht haben darf, gegen den er sich aber wehren soll. Das ist ja genau seine Geschäftsaufgabe. Die müssen ja praktisch den Virus analysieren, um ihn wiedererkennen zu können auf dem System des Kunden, um ihn dann entfernen zu können.
Das ist wie in der Medizin, wenn im Robert-Koch-Institut irgendwo irgendwelche hochgefährlichen Bakterien oder Viren gezüchtet werden, um zu gucken, wie man da ein Gegenmittel herstellt. Die müssen die ja auch haben, um daran zu forschen. So, und damit sind wir bei dem Punkt, wo ihr auch gerne euch beteiligen könnt an der Sendung 0331 70 97 110. Vielleicht arbeitet ihr in der Branche als Programmierer, als Viren-Software-Entwickler, als was auch immer, und ihr seid direkt jetzt gerade von diesem sogenannten Hacker-Gesetz betroffen. Oder aber ihr habt einfach eine Frage dazu, was man da machen kann, oder erkennt jemand, wo das eingetreten ist, was weiß ich, ein Lehrer in einer Schule im Informatikunterricht gibt, bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr raus, weil es eben verboten ist, also unter Strafe steht. Wenn euch sowas passiert ist, dann klingelt uns an, wir würden uns freuen, darüber mit euch zu reden, 0331 70 97 110. Frank, du hast gerade erzählt, Felix, du hast gerade erzählt, du arbeitest auch in einer Firma, die sich mit Computersicherheit und solchen Geschichten beschäftigt. Wie betrifft es denn deine Arbeit jetzt ganz konkret jeden Tag, dieses Gesetz?
Naja, also man muss sagen, nicht alle Sachen, die so eine Firma macht, brauchen jetzt Schadsoftware. Also es gibt auch andere Sachen. Zum Beispiel ist es so, dass Kunden uns gerne mal beauftragen, die geben uns dann den Quellcode von ihrem Programm und den gucken wir uns dann mal an. Da brauchen wir keine Schadsoftware für. Aber der häufige Fall für Sicherheitsfirmen ist, dass jemand einen Webserver betreibt oder einen Mail-Server oder irgendeinen Server im Internet mit irgendeiner anderen Software drauf und der fragt dann eine Firma wie uns, ist das sicher und wir klicken dann mal auf der Seite rum und wir lassen Tools dagegen laufen, das gehört dazu. Und wenn die Tools was finden, dann sagen wir das dem Kunden. Und das Problem ist jetzt, wenn wir in Deutschland sind und die Firma, die wir untersuchen, den Server auch in Deutschland hat, dann können wir die Tools nur noch beschränkt einsetzen. Also wir können nur noch Tools einschränken, bei denen wir das für unzweifelhaft halten, dass sie nicht die Intention haben, jemanden anzugreifen. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Und damit könnt ihr nicht mehr garantieren, dass der Server wirklich sicher ist und damit können wir alle eigentlich mit dem Gedanken leben, dass alle Daten, die von uns irgendwo rumschwirren, sei es Bankdaten oder Zugangsdaten für irgendein Internetportal oder was auch immer, dass die eigentlich auch nicht sicher sind, weil keiner exakt nachprüfen kann, ob das hackbar ist oder nicht.
Naja, also ich kann doch manuell prüfen. Also so ist es nicht, dass ich gar nichts mehr machen kann, wenn ich keine Tools habe. Es ist nur so, dass das eben so eine Art Geheimwissen ist. Also was in einem Tool, was man kaufen kann, da können so was wie 1000 Exploits bei sein. Also von der Größenordnung her immens viele Arten, wie man einen Rechner angreifen kann. Und die müsste ich dann alle im Kopf haben und manuell ausprobieren. Und das ist natürlich erstens eine Sache, die man nicht erwarten kann. Und zweitens dauert es natürlich auch viel länger, wenn ich das manuell mache. Das heißt, üblicherweise zahlt der Kunde für sowas wie eine Woche oder einen Monat oder ist egal, irgendeine Zeiteinheit. Und in der Zeit kann ich entweder ein Tool laufen lassen oder ich kann sagen wir mal ein Zehntel der möglichen Angriffe manuell durchgehen. Also wir haben auf jeden Fall die Situation, dass Kunden in Deutschland jetzt im Grunde schlechteren Service kriegen als sie könnten. Und ich habe da ein sehr anschauliches Beispiel für, das habe ich auch in dem Paper für das Verfassungsgericht geschrieben. Und zwar haben wir einen Kunden gehabt im Ausland, das war eine Bank. Und nun war die immer im Ausland, das heißt, wir konnten da schon Tools anwenden und haben also eine Lücke gefunden auf dem Rechner und haben ein Tool angewendet, um die auszunutzen und haben gesehen, da waren schon andere Leute drauf. Und diese Informationen, die hätten wir einer deutschen Bank nicht geben können an der Stelle. Weil das ein Tool ist, was wir nicht mehr haben dürfen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt...
Und damit sind die Daten der Bank nicht sicher?
Das kann man so nicht sagen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass nicht klar ist, ob eine deutsche Bank, wenn die uns beauftragt hätte und wir hätten nur sagen können, der Server sieht unsicher aus und fix doch mal dieses und jenes, ob die dann auch geguckt hätte, hat da schon jemand drauf rumgehackt. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir jetzt hier Firmen haben in Deutschland, die gar nicht mitkriegen, wenn sie gehackt werden, ist einfach viel höher. Und das ist auch eine Sache, wo wir uns gefragt haben, ist das nicht die Intention der Politiker oder ist das nicht im Grunde dasselbe für die Politiker, wenn sie sagen, wir wollen im Grunde die Rechner sicherer machen, aber das können wir per Gesetz nicht. Also machen wir jetzt dieses Gesetz. Das erreicht auch nicht, dass die Server sicherer werden, aber es erreicht, dass die Leute nicht prüfen können, ob ihre Server sicherer sind und die fühlen sich dann sicherer. Das ist ja wie beim Autofahren. Wenn man nicht ständig im Radio hören würde, es gibt einen Autounfall hier und eine Panne da, dann würde man ja auch denken, da passiert nie was. Das heißt, wenn ich als Serverbetreiber überhaupt nicht mitkriege, dass ich gehackt werde, dann fühle ich mich eventuell sicher, obwohl ich es gar nicht bin. Aber für die Politik ist es ja gleich gut, denn da geht es ja um das Fahrgefühl. Ob der Bürger sich sicher fühlt oder nicht. Wir haben gerade ein sehr lustiges Beispiel aus der Politik. Da hat nämlich der Herr Putin in den Nachrichten gesagt, die russischen Atomkraftwerke sind ja viel sicherer als die anderen, unter anderem die deutschen, weil sie hatten seit zwei Jahren keinen Ausfall mehr.
Genau.
Und genau dasselbe wird bei Computersicherheit auf uns zukommen, dass die Leute sagen, meine Bank wird mir sagen, wir haben seit zwei Jahren sind wir nicht mehr gehackt worden. Jedenfalls, wir wissen von nichts. Und darauf wird dann das Sicherheitsgefühl basieren. Und das ist natürlich schlecht.
Und das hat auch nur jetzt ein konkretes Beispiel. Man kann all diese Probleme natürlich ausweiten. Zum einen auf die Berichterstattung. Also wir sehen jetzt schon, dass vor allen Dingen auch die führenden Online-Magazine wie zum Beispiel bei Heise, aber auch durchaus die kleinen und auch die Forenbetreiber, die so früher Communities gebildet haben oder auch einzelne Programmierer, die Software zur Verfügung gestellt haben, diesen Service einfach einstellen. Die Webseiten werden einfach mit weniger Informationen bestückt oder teilweise ganz geschlossen. Wir sehen jetzt schon eine gewisse Abwanderung. Das heißt, dass Leute, die in dem Bereich arbeiten, die ohnehin hochbezahlte Spezialisten sind, einfach abwandern und sagen, also lass mich hier vom Staat nicht so stark beschneiden in meiner Berufsfreiheit. Und der Druck ist eh schon immer hoch, denn so eine Spezialisten werden überall gut bezahlt. Und die Abwanderung fand schon früher statt und die verstärkt sich jetzt noch. Es gibt vor allen Dingen kleinere und mittlere Firmen, die uns berichten, naja, sie überlegen sich, ob sie langfristig noch hier bleiben können. Denn natürlich haben in der Regel die Kunden, die sich etwa an Firmen wenden, wie jetzt bei Felix, die haben eine Rechtsabteilung, die lassen Sachen prüfen. Die lassen sich vorher teilweise bestätigen, dass bestimmte Hackertudes eben nicht mehr eingesetzt werden, weil sie sich nicht strafbar machen wollen. Die Effekte sind bereits eingetreten und die haben im Endergebnis eigentlich genau die gegenteilige Wirkung von dem, was der Gesetzgeber wollte.
Also wenn wir das ganz kurz jetzt zusammenfassen, diesen Expos, wir haben ja noch eine Menge Zeit in der Sendung. Es gibt ein Gesetz in Deutschland, den sogenannten Hacker Paragraph, Paragraph 202, Strafgesetzbuch. Alle Leute, die sich mit diesem Paragraphen beschäftigen, sagen, dieses Gesetz ist Mumpitz. Trotzdem ist das Ding seit einem Jahr in Kraft. Es gefährdet Arbeitsplätze, es gefährdet die Sicherheit von Servern und von Daten. Und es sorgt für ein Unsicherheitsgefühl, weil keiner mehr wirklich sagen kann, ob Banken, was auch immer, sicher sind oder nicht, weil man es nicht mehr nachprüfen kann. Es ist auch ein Angriff auf die Pressefreiheit. Warum ist dieses Gesetz dann überhaupt auf die Tagesordnung gekommen? Und warum gibt es das, wenn es nur Gegenstimmen gibt und wenn es jetzt schon wieder zur Debatte steht, es abzuschießen?
Das fragen wir uns auch.
Es gibt natürlich zunächst mal eine internationale Grundlage. Da ist die sogenannte Cybercrime Convention. Sodass sich also auf einem internationalen Level Staaten geeinigt haben, wie sie gegen Computerkriminalität weiter vorgehen wollen. Nur, dass man wie der Deutschland da eine Sonderrolle gespielt hat und nicht etwa tatsächlich genau die Intentionen und Formulierungen, wie sie in der Cybercrime Convention stehen, übernommen hat, sondern eben mal ein bisschen darüber hinausgeschossen ist.
Das können wir vielleicht konkret machen. In der Cybercrime Convention steht zum Beispiel drin, Forschung und Lehre dürften nach wie vor Hacker-Tools haben. Also eine Uni, die den Studenten Sicherheit beibringen will, Computersicherheit, die darf auch Hacker-Tools benutzen.
Also jeder Informatikstudent hat das irgendwann mal auf dem Lehrplan. Also wenn du dich damit beschäftigst.
Nein, nein, aber wenn du die Vorlesungen hörst, also A, es darf so eine Vorlesung geben, und B, wenn du sie hörst, dann darfst du da Hacker-Tools drin benutzen.
Und in den Übungen sind Praktika, die dazugehören.
Das macht ja Sinn. Also ich als Firma, ich will ja auch Leute einstellen können. Und jetzt muss man sich schon mal fragen, woher die eigentlich wissen sollen, wie man hackt, wenn sie die Tools nicht haben dürfen. Also die Nachwuchsfrage ist enorm. Die Forschung und Lehre ist betroffen. Und die Pressefreiheit ist betroffen, weil die Zeitungen Mühe haben, dann diese Themen zu covern. Das heißt, es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeiten mehr, außer man ist so ein Autist, der irgendwie seine gesamte Kindheit hinter dem Rechner verbringt und die Sachen alle selbst ausprobiert. Ich meine, solche Leute gibt es. Aber der normale Weg, sich das Wissen anzueigen, ist eben geschlossen mit dem Hacker-2-Paragraphen.
Das heißt, die Leute, die jeden Tag damit arbeiten, die damit zu tun haben, die lassen die Finger davon und machen uns nichts vor. Also es geht ja auch darum, Kriminalität per Online und so per Computer zu unterbinden. Aber die Leute, die wirklich Böses im Schilde führen, denen ist es doch schnuppe, die machen es doch sowieso. 0331-77-97-1-1-0 ist die Nummer vom Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen und mitdiskutieren über diesen ominösen Hacker-Paragraphen, 202c, und am Telefon ist Rainer aus Berlin. Guten Abend, Rainer. Hallo, grüße dich.
Auch, seid gegrüßt. Dazu noch eine Sache. Ihr habt gesagt, dass der Gesetzgeber da irgendwie ein bisschen Mist gebaut hat. Warum geht er davon aus, dass das nicht gewollt ist? Der Bundestrojaner Alaschäuble war im Gespräch, und wenn Privatleute oder Firmen, die keine Schutzvorrichtungen in Form von Hardware oder Software nicht mehr auf den Computer haben dürfen, weil es illegal ist, dann hat der Bundestrojaner die besten Chancen, ins System reinzukommen. Und damit wird natürlich auch der Wirtschaftsspionage-Tür geöffnet. Und das andere Ansatzpunkt wäre, oder Diskussionspunkt, den ich nochmal in den Raum stellen möchte, ist, dass ja durch den Lauf der letzten Jahre das deutsche Bildungssystem auf den Hund gefahren wird. Wir haben nicht die nationale Bewusstsein, dass wir sagen, wir machen nicht mehr alles, was die IG uns vorschreibt, mit. Die Hochschulausbildung, das deutsche Diplom, ist aufgelöst worden. Und es ist eine geringere Qualifikation mit dem Master beziehungsweise des Bachelor, sodass dadurch der Staat auch daran interessiert ist, weniger Fachleute oder ambitionierte Hobbyisten zu haben, die bestimmte Manipulation von ihm aufdecken können. Denn was ist mit den Experten, egal in welcher zeitlichen Epoche sie existiert haben, gemacht worden? Entweder sind sie mundtot gemacht worden, sie werden totgeschwiegen, oder aber sie werden illegalisiert. Und der Staat ist als Gesetzgeber jetzt dabei, Experten, egal ob Firmen oder Hobbyisten, die irgendeine Sache feststellen können, zu illegalisieren damit.
Als Frage an dich, warum sollte der Staat ein Interesse daran haben, die Experten, die ihm auch zu seinem eigenen Schutze dienen sollen, indem sie Hackerangriffe abwehren, zum Beispiel, diese Experten auszuschalten, wie du es gerade formuliert hast?
Für sich selber wird ja nur einen Teil von hochbezahlten Experten brauchen. Und es kann sein, dass er die in den eigenen Reihen ausbildet. Ihr braucht dadurch nicht auf externe, ausgebildete Experten zurückzugreifen.
Aber wie Felix gerade gesagt hat, gibt es ja ein Nachwuchsproblem. Also irgendwoher müssen die Leute ja trotzdem kommen. Das heißt, der Staat würde an seinem eigenen Gesetz vorbei, in seinen eigenen dunklen Mauern Leute ausbilden und draußen alle in Unwissenheit lassen. Ist diese kleine Verschwörungstheorie, die wir gerade hochziehen, oder?
Ja, ich meine, der BND oder der Verfassungsschutz suchen doch in öffentlichen Anzeigen, haben bisher doch ITV-Experten gesucht. Also bisher haben sie die noch von außen reingelassen. Aber wer schließt aus, dass es in Zukunft nicht, entschuldigt bitte, gemanipulierte, hochgezüchtete IT-Experten geben könnte, wenn der Ansatz ist von Intel, dass es demnächst Computer geben könnte, die mit Gedanken gesteuert werden. Und in der Medizin sind bei Menschen, die Gehirnschäden haben, dort die ersten Anritze zu sehen.
Okay, jetzt machst du aber eine ziemlich dicke Verschwörungstheorie auf. Aber wenn ich mal den Kernpunkt zum Hackerparagraph zusammenfassen sollte, so siehst du schon eine Möglichkeit, dass der Staat hier nicht schlampig gearbeitet hat, sondern tatsächlich ein gewisses Ziel dahintersteckt, nämlich eine Kriminalisierung von bestimmten Benutzern.
Da gibt es ja jetzt also diese zwei Stränge, die man in der Argumentation um diesen Hackerparagraph nehmen kann. Das eine ist, dass dieses Gesetz mumpelts ist, was alle Experten gerade sagen, und dass darüber diskutiert wird, ob das Gesetz wieder abgeschafft wird, weil einfach geschlammt wurde, wie Corns auch gerade gesagt hat. Oder aber, wie Reinhardt gerade sagt, da steckt schon eine Absicht dahinter. Ansatz zum Beispiel, Bundesdrianer, Ansatz zum Beispiel, der Staat bildet seine eigenen Leute aus, die sich um die Sicherheit kümmern und lässt alle anderen außen vor, um da so eine Verschwörungstheorie hochzuziehen. Das sind diese beiden Argumentationslinien, oder?
Wir müssen da eigentlich den Verschwörungsexperten, der zufällig heute im Studio ist, nach vorfragen.
Ja, also grundsätzlich ja. Ich meine, ich bin ja auch ein Freund von Verschwörungstheorien. Und ich denke auch, dass es da...
Ok, Verschwörungstheorie-Modus ein.
Genau. Also ich denke auch, dass es da nicht so was entsteht, nicht zufällig oder durch Inkompetenz, sondern da ist ein Plan dahinter, den wir noch nicht verstanden haben. Aber die einzelnen Punkte kann man alle angreifen. Also sagen wir mal, der Bundestrojaner, da sieht man gerade Saarland und Bayern sowieso, haben beschlossen, dass der nicht mehr übers Internet installiert werden muss, sondern dass jemand in deine Wohnung einbricht und den auf deinem Rechner aufbringt. Und da brauchst du kein Spezialwissen für, das kann man alles jetzt schon machen und das wird sich auch nicht schließen lassen. Physischer Zugriff auf den Rechner ist immer total Verlust. Da kannst du nichts machen, um nichts zu sichern. Auch nicht Plattenverschlüsselung, das kann man alles umgehen. Also der Bundestrojaner braucht keine Experten. Dann, es gab eine lustige zeitliche Koinzidenz, dass das BKA tatsächlich in öffentlichen Ausschreibungen nach Leuten gesucht hat, die den Bundestrojaner programmieren. Und da haben wir uns dann auch gut über lustig gemacht. Aber also die Theorie, dass der Staat irgendwelche Forschungslabore hat, wo jetzt Geheimwissen ist, das mag irgendwie mal gewesen sein in den 60ern, 70ern im Kalten Krieg. Aber heutzutage sieht man ja ganz gut eigentlich an Forschungssachen, was die veröffentlichen, wie stolz sie darauf sind und wie viel dann dahinter ist. Und ich persönlich glaube nicht, dass die irgendwelche Supermutanten da in ihren Bunkern haben, die irgendwie super toll rechnen können. Was ich aber noch sagen möchte, ist, was wir jetzt hier auch gerade haben, so ein Motiv, was die Politiker gerne vorbringen, das kommt von der EU, das mussten wir umsetzen. Das möchte ich so nicht stehen lassen. Denn die EU, da sind wir ein Teil davon. Und die Deutschen sind sogar stolz darauf gewesen, die ersten mit dem Signaturgesetz gewesen zu sein. Die Deutschen sind schon von Anfang an federführend in Computersachen. Also das ist nicht so, wenn wir das nicht hätten haben wollen, dass wir dieses Hypercrime Convention nicht hätten verhindern können. Das heißt, die Deutschen wollten das, wenn sie nicht sogar dafür gesorgt haben, dass es durchkommt. Das lässt sich im Nachhinein immer so ein bisschen schwer rekonstruieren. Ich glaube, die, die es eingebracht haben, waren die Briten.
Und die Amerikaner sind an diesem Verhaut dabei. Es sind natürlich schon auf jeden Fall die Staaten der ersten Welt, die da federführend waren, um eben gemeinschaftlich eine Strategie zu entwickeln.
Also unsere Regierung. Und das ist eine Sache, die man häufiger sieht bei Gesetzen, wenn sie die im Inland nicht durchkriegen oder wenn sie glauben, sie kriegen sie im Inland nicht durch, dann machen sie das auf EU-Ebene und sagen danach, das muss man jetzt aber ins nationale Gesetz umsetzen.
Und dann nochmal mit der Argumentationslinie, das ist eine EU-Richtlinie, da müssen wir folgen.
Und wenn sie dann noch weitergehen in dem nationalen Gesetz, als die EU-Vorgabe ist, dann das sehe ich als klares Zeichen dafür, dass die eigentliche Idee von der EU-Vorgabe von uns kam und dass wir die auf EU-Ebene nicht in ganz durchgesetzt gekriegt haben und dass die Politiker in Deutschland jetzt kommen und halt den Teil, den sie eigentlich haben wollten, ins nationale Gesetz dazutun. Das kann man ja sehen.
Also ihr seht, es gibt eine ganze Menge Diskussionspunkte rund um diesen sogenannten Hackerparagraphen. Damit werden wir uns auch weiterhin beschäftigen. Hier im Chaosradio, wir machen jetzt erstmal die Nachrichten rein. Und dir vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und alle anderen können mitdiskutieren unter 0331 70 97 110. Chaos Radio auf Fritz.
Fritz präsentiert das Monkey Island Festival auf der Insel der Jugend. Das schrägste und klimafreundlichste Festival der Saison. Mit 21 energiegeladenen Bands Kreuz und Quer aus der Artenvielfalt des Berliner Underglads.
In einem Dschungel direkt an der Spring.
Das Monkey Island Festival. Kommenden Samstag. Auf der Insel der Jugend Berlin Treto. Ach ja. Schräg und klimafreundlich.
FritzInfo.
Nachrichten. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die Berliner Regelung zum Rauchverbot in der Gastronomie gekippt. Nach dem Urteil ist Rauchen in Einraumkneipen vorerst unter Auflagen wieder erlaubt. Die Richter sahen die Betroffenen wirtebenachteilig gegenüber den Betreibern größerer Gaststätten, in denen in abgetrennten Räumen geraucht werden darf. Bis Ende 2009 muss das Gesetz geändert werden. Entweder gibt es dann Ausnahmeregelung für alle oder ein allgemeines Rauchverbot. Chinas Zensur von Internetseiten bei den Olympischen Spielen ist weltweit auf scharfe Proteste gestoßen. US-Präsident Bush forderte China auf, das Internet ohne Beschränkungen freizugeben. Der Vorsitzende des Sportausschusses im Bundestag dankert es dafür, die weltweite Fernsehübertragung der Öffnungsfeier abzusagen, wenn China nicht einlenke. Der CDU-Außenpolitiker Poland sagte, dass die Hardliner im chinesischen Politbüro sich bestätigt fühlten, wenn die Zensur hingenommen werde. Verbraucher sollen in Zukunft besser vor unerwünschten Werbeanrufen geschützt werden. Das Bundeskabinett hat heute einen entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf beschlossen. Bei unerlaubter Telefonwerbung drohen Firmen demnach bis zu 50.000 Euro Strafe. Außerdem müssen Callcenter, die ihre Rufnummer unterdrücken, bis zu 10.000 Euro zahlen. Bundestag und Bundesrat müssen noch zustimmen. Der Berliner SPD-Chef Müller will den Anstieg der Mieten in Berlin dämpfen. Müller sagte der Online-Ausgabe der Berliner Morgenpost, dass die soziale Mischung erhalten werden solle. So solle Mietspiegel 2009 die Spannel für Erhöhung eingeschränkt und neue Kriterien wie Verkehrslam und Energiebedarf der Wohnung aufgenommen werden. Israels Ministerpräsident Olmert hat seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Er erklärte am Abend, dass er sich bei der Wahl im September nicht mehr um den Vorsitz der regierenden Kadima-Partei bewerben will, er stehe dann auch nicht mehr als Regierungschef bereit. Olmert wird Bestechlichkeit vorgeworfen. Er bestreitet das. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt 21, Potsdam Cottbus Neuruppin 22, Angermünde 23, Wittenberge 25 und in Berlin sind es so um die 23 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es nur wenig bewölkt und meist trocken, bei Tiefstwerte von 18 Grad. Morgen soll es wieder ganz viel Sonne geben und das bei Höchstwerten bis zu 32 Grad. Mit einigen Meldungen in Hennigsdorf statt Einwerz gibt es an der Spandauer Straße einen umgekippten Baum, der wird beseitigt dort bitte vorsichtig. Dann auf der A105 Abzweig Reinickendorf zwischen Kurt Schumacher Platz und Kreuz Reinickendorf ist in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Dort wird eine Brücke abgerissen. Das Ganze kann auch etwas dauern. Und eine letzte Meldung auf der A111 Stadt Autobahn statt Einwerz zwischen Heckerdamm und Dreieck Charlottenburg. Dort ist gesperrt. Auch dort wird gebaut. Ansonsten eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2?
Blue, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Chaosradio 137 auf Fritz. Es gab übrigens auch in den Wiki-Seiten zur Sendung ein Musikwunsch, dem wollen wir natürlich gerne nachkommen. Wir machen hier kein Musikwunschradio, sondern Chaosradio, aber der passt hervorragend. Fahr den Urlaub, lieber Staat. Der Kollege Jan Fedder, alias Farinurlaub, unser Racing-Team, lieber Staat, Mittwochabend kurz nach halb elf, Chaos Radio auf Fritz, halb 137, heute geht's um den Hacker-Paragraphen, Konzi-CF, Fefe ist auch da und wir wollen mit euch über diesen, über dieses Gesetz, was eigentlich keiner haben will, was jetzt trotzdem irgendwie da ist, wo alle Leute sagen, das ist Mumpitz und wo ein paar Leute sagen, ja vielleicht ist doch aber eine Idee dahinter. Darüber würden wir gerne mit euch reden. 0331 70 97 110. Guten Abend, André. Hallo. Von wo rufst du an, wenn du das sagen möchtest?
Ich rufe aus Berlin und die Frage ist folgende. Ich bin selbst Programmier und Elektroniker. Zwar kein Hacker, aber ich habe eine Firma, die einen Zolllager betreibt und Zoll begann sich für Steuern.
Was betreibst du? Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Einen Zolllager.
Einen Zolllager, okay, alles klar.
Ganz genau. Also, wer jemand irgendwas imbattieren will und weiter durch Deutschland weiterführen will, muss entweder Steuern zahlen, oder man zahlt das nicht, dann geht es durch so einen Zolllager.
Alles klar, okay. Und dieses Zolllager machst du und du wartest dann darauf, dass irgendjemand kommt und seine Steuern zahlt?
Na ja, normalerweise fliegt das Geld in Form von Waren. Und der Staat guckt ganz sorgfältig, dass die Waren, die durch Deutschland gehen, nicht in Deutschland landen. Ansonsten muss ich so genannt...
versteuert werden. Aber das ist jetzt schon wieder kaufmännisches Fachwissen.
Aber das ist Geld. Also das System, was man dafür verwendet, heißt Atlas. Das ist ein europäisches System. Und die müssen wir als Pflicht einsetzen. Und in diesen Paragraphen von Zollkodek steht auch, dass ich für die Sicherheit dieser Systeme auch zuständig bin. Weil wir betreiben das auch selbst. Also da sind die Provider und so weiter. Das Problem ist, dass zum Beispiel per Hand kann ich viele Dinge überhaupt gar nicht prüfen. Also das ist einfach nicht machbar. Ich kann einfach nicht prüfen, ob mein Server 20.000, 30.000 Anfragen einfach bearbeiten kann oder der jetzt abstürzt oder noch sowas. Das musst du doch irgendeinem Tool machen, so oder so. Und jetzt bin ich sozusagen zwischen zwei Feuern. Einerseits kann ich das nicht prüfen, andererseits muss ich das prüfen. Und ich werde in dem Fall und in dem Fall dafür belangt.
Weil du hast auf der einen Seite die Verpflichtung, dass dieses System läuft. Du bist dafür verantwortlich, dass es sicher ist. Auf der anderen Seite, wie du gerade gesagt hast, kannst du diese Tools nicht einsetzen, die du dafür brauchtest, weil dann würdest du dich strafbar machen. Und damit haben wir, was wir am Anfang der Sendung auch schon mal hatten, dass dieses Gesetz unter anderem auch eine Unsicherheit schafft, eine Rechtsunsicherheit und auch für Arbeitsplätze gefährlich ist.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, denn oftmals ist man aufgrund anderer Gesetze verpflichtet. Bei dir jetzt zum Beispiel, aber durchaus auch in vielen anderen Beispielen, etwa aus Datenschutzgründen oder aus Aufbewahrungspflichten. Man hat ja andere gesetzliche Pflichten, die man erfüllen muss. Zum anderen gibt es aber auch noch den ganzen Bereich der Versicherung. Wenn man noch gut versichert sein will, wenn man gezwungen ist, auf die Datensicherheit zu achten, gibt es da viele Bereiche. Ein klassischer Konfliktfeld.
Was kann Andre jetzt machen?
Es ist ja so, wenn jetzt bei ihm eine Unsicherheit in dem System ist und das benutzt wird, dann wird er nachweisen müssen, dass er das, was er tun konnte, getan hat. Insofern, wenn er die Tools nicht anwenden durfte, dann wird man ihm das nicht vorwerfen können. Also da will ich mir jetzt persönlich keine Sorgen machen, aber es ist juristisch alles andere als klar. Das betrifft übrigens auch andere Leute, die Firmen betreiben. Also gerade für Banken und Versicherungen gibt es stricte Regeln, die unter anderem für den Notfall, was meines Wissens so gut wie nie vorkommt, den Vorstand persönlich haftbar machen, wenn der versäumt hat, irgendein Problem zu beheben, ein Sicherheitsproblem. Also ja, das betrifft viele Leute und das ist auch der Grund, warum die Industrie geschlossen gegen das Gesetz gewesen ist. Eine andere Sache, die mir gerade auffällt, die jetzt möglicherweise den betrifft, also nehmen wir mal an, du hast in deinem Zolllager einen Computer sitzen und den holt keiner ab. Dann ist der ja in deinem Besitz. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt juristisch hinkommt, aber ich möchte auf einen Punkt hin. Bei dem Hacker-Tool-Paragraphen handelt es sich nämlich um ein Offizialsdelikt. Das heißt, nehmen wir an, die Polizei kommt aus irgendeinem völlig anderen Grund und guckt diesen Computer mit an und findet darauf ein Hacker-Tool. Dann müssen die das untersuchen. Das ist einfach die Kategorie von Rechtsverstoß, den diese Hacker-Tool-Paragraph besitzt.
Also das heißt...
Kurz erklären. Offizialsdelikt ist also so ein Delikt, wo der Staat von sich aus anfangen muss zu ermitteln und also keine Anzeige oder so erfolgen muss. Das unterscheidet den Offizialsdelikt eben von anderen Delikten.
Genau. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel jemand auf der Straße irgendwie Müll rumliegen lässt und jemand anderes beobachtet den und zeigt ihn an, dann müssten die das auch machen, dann müssten die das auch bearbeiten. Aber wenn man jetzt einfach Müll auf der Straße liegen sieht, dann müssten die nicht in Ermittlungen los treten. Also bei kleineren Sachen ist das nicht so, aber bei Mord zum Beispiel, ganz klar ist das so, dass wenn der Staat feststellt, dass es begangen worden ist, dann muss das untersucht werden. Und das gilt unter anderem eben auch für Beifunde. Also das heißt, wenn die noch was völlig anderes gesucht haben und sie finden versehentlich auch ein Hackertool, dann müssen sie Ermittlungen einleiten.
Aber in dem Fall ist André doch nur der, der diese Zolllage hat, wo der Computer steht.
Richtig. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man ihm das anheften kann. Sagen wir mal, er importiert was, will es eigentlich weitergeben. Aber die Firma, die es abholen wollte, taucht nicht auf. Und dann sitzt er auf der Ware und muss sie zurückschicken. Und vielleicht gibt es da ein Zeitfenster, wo es offiziell... Ich weiß nicht. Also theoretisch, wenn jemand bei dir... Also normalerweise ist es ja so, jemand sucht dein Auto, weil sie glauben, du hast jemanden angefahren und sie finden irgendwie Drogenreste, dann wirst du wegen den Drogen belangt, ja? Und dasselbe gilt jetzt eben auch für Haka-Tools. Wenn da eine CD liegt und da sind irgendwelche Haka-Tools drauf, dann wirst du eben auch dafür belangt, dass es auch ein Offiziarztin liegt.
Weil ich kriege auch sehr viel wissenschaftliche Geräte und auch sehr viel auch in den T-Bereich, auch die ganzen Labore, die logischerweise werden auch mit Software ausgestattet und von Hersteller selbst, also wir arbeiten sehr eng zusammen mit Wiemens, Motorola und Cisco zum Beispiel. Da liefern wir die ganze Technik, die nach Osteroper geht. Und ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass da einfach die Prüfzüge dabei sind, weil die Leute, die müssen das irgendwie installieren und den Gang kriegen.
Ja klar, da kannst du dir auch sicher sein, da ja normale Betriebssysteme ohnehin Hacker Tools mitliefern. Die sind einfach Bestandteile des Betriebssystems.
Ein normales Betriebssystem beinhaltet Hacker Tools, das heißt eigentlich dürfen ja dann Betriebssysteme gar nicht ausgeliefert werden.
Das hat auch nochmal so ein strittiger Punkt.
Also eigentlich dürfte es ab morgen nirgends mehr Computer mit vorinstalliertem Windows Vista zu kaufen geben, weil da ist ja ein Hacker Tool drauf.
Also soll man mal konkret Internet Explorer ist drauf.
Ja, man muss sich mal vergegenwärtigen.
Ah und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Punkt, keiner weiß, was ein Hacker Tool ist.
Drei Viertel aller Angriffe werden mit einem Webbrowser durchgeführt. Also klassischerweise das meistverbreitete Angriffstool in Webbrowser. Aber was ich jetzt meinte, sind natürlich schon eher Netzwerktools, die man so braucht. Also mein Betriebssystem hat eine Handvoll, die ist ohnehin schon installiert. Bei den üblichen Linux-Betriebssystemen sind das sogar relativ viel.
Also das klassische Beispiel unter Linux ist Ping. Mit Ping guckt man normalerweise nach, ist der Rechner da, aber es gibt halt auch eine Flat-Option. Damit kann man eigentlich gucken, wie viele Pakete gehen verloren, wenn ich volle Pulle rausschicke. Und das ist eben auch ein Deal-on-Off-Service. Also wenn ich die Leitung komplett saturieren kann, dann kann ich damit andere Rechner platt machen. Und das ist ein Angriffstool, klar.
Da wäre zum Beispiel auch klassischerweise noch der Partscanner, den etwa mein Betriebssystem mitliefert, der ist da drauf.
Genau. Und wenn man, sagen wir mal, einen Cisco-Router angreifen will, dann würde man Telnet benutzen und das ist bei Windows auch dabei.
Genau.
Also wenn man anfängt, die Sachen wörtlich zu interpretieren, dann kann man verdammt viele Sachen konstruieren, bei denen nicht klar ist, dass es kein Hackertool ist.
Okay, und dann sind wir wieder bei einem der Kritikpunkte an diesem Hackergesetz, um was es heute geht, dass gar nicht so genau klar ist, was das eigentlich jetzt konkret beinhaltet. Also wenn ihr jetzt gerade sagt, ein Browser, 70% aller Angriffe werden mit einem Browser veranstaltet und die normalen Dinge wie Portscanner und so sind sowieso mit dabei, das würde ja bedeuten, dass auf jedem Computer, der zu Hause in irgendeinem Haus steht, dass auf jedem Computer so was installiert ist. Und dass jeder Computer damit theoretisch unter dieses Gesetz fallen würde.
Das Problem ist eben genau diese schlampige Formulierung, weil im Text steht, dass es um Computerprogramme geht, deren Zweck die Begehung einer Straftat ist, also in diesem Fall Ausspähen oder Abfangen von Daten. Und wir haben prinzipiell nachgedacht, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, dass man den Zweck einer Software bestimmen kann. Und wir denken eigentlich nein, denn nur die Umstände, die etwa der User oder die Konfiguration, in der das Tool benutzt wird, bestimmen eigentlich erst den Zweck. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich ein klassischer juristischer Zirkus. Man kann den Zweck nicht bestimmen.
Wie verhält sich denn die Juristerei im Bezug auf dieses Gesetz, wenn da die Rechtslage so undeutig ist?
Das ist auch ungemein kritisch. Man kann nicht auch nachlesen, denn die Juristen haben ja, wie alle anderen Beteiligten im Rechtsausschuss, lange Stellungnahmen abgegeben. Man kann jetzt in vielen von diesen computerbezogenen Rechtszeitschriften, wie z.B. bei Computer und Recht, in Zeitschriften eine Menge nachlesen. Auch die Juristen sind sehr kritisch.
Wenn man jetzt einen Juristen fragt, was ich mal getan habe, muss ich mir den jetzt Sorgen machen? Hat er gesagt, im Moment noch nicht, denn es gibt noch keine gerichtliche Klärung. So sehen das die meisten Juristen aus der Praxis. Die sagen nämlich, bevor es die ersten Urteile dazu gibt, muss man sich da keine Sorgen machen. Aber so eine gewisse Unsicherheit bleibt natürlich.
Zurück zur Situation von André. Wir machen gleich weiter am Thema. Wenn André gerade sagt, er steht zwischen zwei Feuern. Auf der einen Seite ist er dafür verantwortlich, dass die Systeme sicher laufen. Auf der anderen Seite kann er das nicht überprüfen, weil er die Tools nicht benutzen kann. Felix sagt gerade, solange du nachweisen kannst, dass du alles in deiner Macht Stehende auf legalem Weg getan hast, dann kann dir eigentlich keiner was.
Kann natürlich immer noch heißen, dass die Firma gehackt wird. Und dann ist er pleite. Dann kann er zwar nichts, aber ist trotzdem pleite.
Das ist auch nicht unbedingt schön. Das ist ja eine Sache.
Ja, natürlich. Deswegen sage ich das.
Bei mir im Lager liegen wissenschaftliche Geräte. Jeder weiß, was so ein Allergynx-Scanner kostet. Da kostet so ein Ink über 100.000. Ich kann ja sagen, bei mir im Lager liegen, sage ich mal, zig Millionen Euro nur Steuergeld. Es geht darum, dass irgendjemand auch rauskriegt, was da drin ist und einfach den Lager direkt angreift. Was sagen wir dann? Ich muss meinen Bestand quasi eventuell ausliefern. Ich kann mich nicht schützen. Ich bin einfach verpflichtet, mich offen zu lassen, so wie es ist. Das bedeutet, wenn einer in den Lager reingeht, dann weiß er ganz genau, an welchen Stellen die teuersten Geräte liegen und an welchen Stellen braucht man ja gar nichts zu gucken. Da geht es nicht nur um Geld. Wir wollen zum Beispiel 40.000 Quadratmeter schützen. Da muss ich schon wirklich die Leute mit Schusswaffen erst mal aufstellen, die fast jede Bedrohung abschießen oder so.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall ist das jetzt eine Situation, wo wir dir hier wahrscheinlich weniger weiterhelfen können. Da macht es Sinn, mal mit der Rechtsabteilung von der Firma, für die du arbeitest, zu reden, um sich da mal genauere Informationen zu holen. Aber André, danke dir für deinen Anruf, weil ich glaube, wir haben einen weiteren Aspekt von diesem Hackerparagraphen jetzt mal gesehen. Du hast irgendwie ein Lagerhaus oder irgendwas, ein Kaufhaus oder so, und du gibst irgendwo ein Warenbestandssystem. Und da steht drin, was steht wo, wie und warum. Und wenn ich da drauf gucken kann, weiß ich genau, wo ich die Kaffeemaschine finde und muss beim nächsten Mal nicht lange durchs Haus tausen und die suchen, wenn ich die kaufen will.
Also das führt zu zwei Überlegungen. Die erste, also vielleicht nur mal zu begründen, warum ein Browser ein Attack-Tool ist. Es gibt jemanden, der hat in JavaScript einen Portscanner geschrieben. Und die Idee dabei ist, dass man quasi hinter einer Firewall Portscannt, indem man einen User dazu bringt, dass er auf meine Webseite geht und da ist dieser JavaScript Portscanner. Also der kann jetzt nicht auf alle Ports gehen, weil da gibt es Beschränkungen, aber es ist im Grunde ein Portscanner und ein Portscanner fällt unter die Definition von Nacca-Tool, da sind sich die Massen Leute einig. Das heißt, wenn ich mit meinem normalen Browser, der ist programmierbar in JavaScript, auf eine Webseite gehe, wo ein JavaScript liegt, der meinen Browser dazu bringt, Sachen zu tun, die als Angriff gewertet werden können, dann kann man jetzt natürlich sagen, der JavaScript ist das Angriffstool. Aber man kann auch sagen, der Browser, der ja eigentlich die Arbeit ausführt, ist das Angriffstool. Das heißt, selbst wenn das Tool selbst überhaupt gar nicht die Intention hat, irgendeinen Ärger zu machen, was beim Browser ja gegeben ist, kann es trotzdem ein Angriffstool werden, selbst wenn ich es gar nicht bösartig benutze. Also, die technischen Details sind so verzwickt, dass man im Grunde schon deswegen sagen kann, um Gottes Willen.
Also nur weil du dir ein großes Auto gekauft hast und vergessen hast, die Handbremse anzuziehen, kannst du nicht dafür belangt werden, wenn das Auto rückwärts rollt und den Hund von der Nachbarin...
Oh doch, das wäre fahrlässig.
Es gibt schon Fahrlässigkeit, also so ist es nicht. Worauf ich auch noch ganz wichtig finde, ist, wir haben jetzt gesagt, das Gesetz ist handwerklich schlecht. Wir haben gesagt, die Definition ist schlecht. Aber was mir sehr wichtig ist und was ich auch in dem Ausschuss gesagt habe, selbst wenn es eine perfekte Definition gäbe, was ein Angriffszool ist, dann wäre das Gesetz immer noch schlecht. Denn ein Virus oder ein Wurm fällt mit Sicherheit unter diese perfekte Definition. Es ist ein Stück Kot, das den Zweck hat, andere Leute zu infizieren und ihnen Schaden zuzufügen. Aber ein Antivirushersteller braucht ein Virus, um eine Erkennung von diesem Virus zu schreiben. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt sagen, per Gesetz ist es verboten, eine Schadsoftware zu haben, dann machen wir praktisch den Antivirushersteller aus Deutschland. Da gibt es welche. Arbeitslos an der Stelle.
Man muss einfach mal die Mechanismen sehen, wie heute, wenn man forscht oder sich beruflich damit befasst oder auch in der Uni durchaus, wie die Mechanismen funktionieren. Man kann natürlich nur dann Schritt halten mit den typischen Kriminellen, die eben so eine Schadsoftware einsetzen, wenn man diese genau analysiert. Wenn man sie auch benutzt, wenn man versucht, selber so zu denken wie ein Angreifer, also eigene Schadsoftware schreibt und Mechanismen rauskriegt. Man braucht gleichzeitig den Austausch. Man muss sich mit anderen Leuten, die andere Erfahrungen machen, austauschen dürfen darüber. All das ist beschränkt worden. Hier ist ein richtiger Standortnachteil entstanden. Anderswo auf der Welt machen das die IT-Sicherheitsforscher weiterhin, sowohl im universitären Bereich, in der Berufsausbildung, aber auch im beruflichen Bereich. Hier in Deutschland sind jetzt plötzlich bestimmte Bereiche ganz klar illegal und vor allen Dingen eine Menge graue Zonen entstanden.
Da kommt jetzt die Frage von Rüdiger, der uns angerufen hat unter 0371 77 97 110. Rüdiger will nämlich wissen, was ist, wenn man so eine Programme besitzt. Das ist ja dann auch schon strafbar.
Was besitzt du denn?
Na ja, das geht jetzt nicht darum, was man besitzt. Es geht einfach darum, dass man ja, was weiß ich, über Jahre seine laufenden Programme, die man sich ständig installiert hat, irgendwo auf CDs weggebrannt hat. Da liegen Berge von CDs. Die guckt man sich eigentlich nicht wieder an. Und die Frage ist jetzt, bin ich jetzt verpflichtet, rechtlich die Dinge durchzugrasen, ob ich dann zum Beispiel kein Unabel da drauf nochmal finde?
Ach je, ob du heute noch an das Hackertool gelten würdest, weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Ich denke schon.
Also das ist deswegen ein interessanter Punkt, weil es Backup-Systeme gibt, aus denen man alte Sachen nicht löschen kann, weil die Backups nämlich inkrementell sind. Das heißt, wenn du anfängst, da Sachen draus zu löschen, inkrementell, das heißt, man speichert quasi die Unterschiede zum letzten Backup. Und es gibt es auch auf Verschlüsselungsbasis. Also es gibt Systeme, wo man die Integrität des aktuellen Backups nur prüfen kann, wenn man auch alle anderen älteren Backups betrachtet. Und wenn ich jetzt anfange, aus den alten Backups irgendwelche Hacker-Tools rauszulöschen, dann kompromittiere ich das gesamte Backup-System. Alles, was ich dann schreibe.
Weil bei dir plötzlich sagt, das Puzzle passt nicht zusammen.
Genau. Also das heißt, auch hier gibt es technische Details, die mit Sicherheit keiner von denen wusste, die dieses Gesetz geschrieben haben, und die aber in der Praxis verheerend sind. Also ja, das ist eine Frage, die man sich stellen muss. Was mache ich jetzt mit meinen Tools? Normalerweise, wenn man solche Gesetze macht, dann gibt es so eine Art Grandfather Clause, nennt sich das im Englischen, dann heißt es Tools, die vor dem Inkrafttreten des Gesetzes beschafft wurden, fallen nicht darunter. Naja, aber das gibt es in diesem Fall nicht. Das steht nicht im Gesetz drin und daher ist es eine offene Frage.
Also es ist eben vor allen Dingen auch nicht nur der Besitz von diesen neuen alten oder sonst was für Hacker Tools, sondern natürlich auch die Verbreitung. Also du dürfest sie natürlich auch niemanden anders geben, oder du dürfest sie auch niemanden anders zugänglich machen. Auch das ist im Gesetz so festgeschrieben.
Das heißt, nehmen wir an, du findest jetzt irgendein Tool und weißt gar nicht mehr, was es tut, und würdest jetzt gerne mich damit beauftragen, dass ich mir das ansehe und dir sage, ob das ein Hacker Tool ist, geht auch nicht. Genau. Also in dem Gesetz steht ja nicht drin, dass du wissen musst, dass es ein Hacker Tool ist, sondern es geht von dem Zweck der Software aus. Also das ist, im Grunde gibt es niemanden, der dieses Gesetz erfüllen kann.
Aber wenn dieses Gesetz sagt, Hacker Tools sind quasi, ich mach es mal ganz pauschal, Hacker Tools sind böse, böse, böse, dann muss es doch eine Liste geben, auf der drauf steht, diese Hacker Tools sind böse, böse, böse und die anderen sind es nicht. Aber alleine diese Liste an sich ist ja dann schon wieder sehr suspekt, oder?
Na, die Liste gibt es nicht. Und die kann es auch nicht geben, weil es nämlich pro Minute irgendwie einen neuen Virus gibt.
Ja klar. Und es wäre auch unsinnig, denn man braucht natürlich auch genau diese Software auf der Liste. Man benötigt tatsächlich diese Schadsoftware, weil man kann die nicht bekämpfen, weil man nicht die Mechanismen kennt. Und man kann auch sich nicht wirklich weiterbilden, wenn man sich nicht in das Mindset von einem Angreifer versetzen kann und tatsächlich dieselben Methoden verwendet. Das ist einfach unsinnig. Da hat jemand nicht verstanden, wie Sicherheitsforschung funktioniert.
Da muss man noch eine Stufe draufsetzen.
Wenn man sich zum Beispiel anguckt, wie teilweise Virenscanner heute arbeiten, dann liefern sie zu Teilen Code des Virenscanners mit.
Einfach zum Vergleich.
Für die Heuristiken.
Also jeder Hersteller, der in Deutschland einen Virenscanner anbietet, der mit diesen Techniken arbeitet, verbreitet im Prinzip permanent nach dem Hackerparagraphen unter Strafe gestellten Programm Code.
Na gut, also man kann jetzt sagen, das ist nur ein Auszug und das wäre an sich nicht so schlimm.
Ich denke schon, dass das genau der fünfte Teil des Viruses enthalten ist.
Technisch hast du sicher recht, also formal juristisch. Allerdings, also man muss ja sagen, die Sache, die auf der einen Seite gut, auf der anderen Seite aber auch furchtbar ist, ist, dass eben am Ende der Richter entscheidet. Und der Richter ist im Zweifelsfall ein 60-Jähriger beim Amtsgericht.
Ohne jetzt irgendeinem Richter zu nahe drücken.
Nein, aber ich meine, wir haben im Club dieses Wort für sowas, das sind die E-Mail-Ausdrucker. Die lassen sich jeden Morgen das Internet ausdrucken. Der selber kann überhaupt keine Tastatur bedienen. Und wenn man dem mit Konzepten wie Virus und replizierender Software kommt, dann ist der total überfordert. Und auf der einen Seite kann das gut für dich ausgehen. Auf der anderen Seite kann das eben auch heißen, dass er eine Software, die er nicht kennt, erst mal als Schadsoftware einstuft. Also das ist einfach Rechtsunsicherheit. Und das ist an sich schon eine schlechte Sache.
Ich finde, Beide würden genau das in seinen Urteil schreiben, was in der Stadt war, weil die nie Anklage gemacht hat.
Genau. Und der hat auch keine Ahnung. Der hat vielleicht Aliens gesehen im Fernsehen und denkt, irgendwie Software, Computer, mit denen spricht man heute.
Also ich finde das Beispiel eigentlich auch ganz schön. Man könnte sogar noch ein Stück weiter denken. Wenn du dir mal überlegst, wenn du an einem beliebigen Zeitpunkt deine Inbox aufklappst, wie viele Schadprogramme sich alleine in zwei Stunden ansammeln, die du einfach auf deinen Rechner kriegst. Egal, ob sie gleich weggeschmissen werden oder noch eine Stunde durch den Spam-Assassin oder wie auch immer. Man braucht eigentlich nur noch eine Mehrdrasse benutzen, um beliebige Mengen von Schadsoftware einzusammeln, die einem einfach zugeschickt werden.
Das ist überhaupt eine interessante Frage, ob man nicht Nigeria-Scam auch als Schadsoftware bezeichnen könnte. Weil da steht ja eigentlich immer, wenn man da nur genügend breit mit seiner Definition rangeht. Also E-Mail finde ich eine sehr gute Sache. Es gibt aber auch noch, um ein bisschen zu beleuchten, wie die Branchen funktionieren, es gibt das Konzept namens Honeynet. Das funktioniert so, dass man einen Rechner aufsetzt, der bewusst unsicher konfiguriert ist und hofft, dass der gehackt wird, damit man sehen kann, wie der gehackt wird.
Der heißt aber Honeypot.
Also es gibt zwei Sachen. Es gibt Honeypot, das ist der Rechner, und es gibt ein Honeynet, das ist ein ganzes Netzwerk von unsicheren Rechnern.
Und auf jeden Fall wird gleich wieder eine Nummer größer.
Also du stellst den Schokoriegel auf die Wiese und wartest, bis die Westen kommen.
Genau. Deswegen heißt es auch Honeypot ursprünglich, der Rechner. Das ist einfach ein Pot mit Honig. Dem gibt man dann am besten noch einen Namen, der super klingt, wie irgendwie, was weiß ich, Vault.Bank.de oder keine Ahnung. Und dann hofft man eben, dass jemand kommt und den aufhackt und möglich Spuren hinterlässt von irgendwelchen Rootkits oder...
Und dann hat dieser Spuren kannst du dann arbeiten.
Das ist natürlich ein Hackertool, was man dann da findet. Aber so funktioniert das heute. Also die meisten aktuellen Informationen über Angriffe, die wir haben, die kommen von solchen Honeypots. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt sagen, der Besitz von Hackertools ist verboten, dann ist das wie so ein Tuch über den Augen von der Sicherheitsbranche. Weil dann werden wir einfach viel gar nicht mehr mitkriegen.
Das bedeutet Besitz auch schon, das was Konz eben angesprochen hat, diese Ansammlung an Spam-Mails in meinem Mail-Inbox.
Nach dem Wortlaut würde es dazu gehören. Man darf es nicht besitzen.
Das heißt, ich kann auch nicht mal dafür, wenn ich mich voll spamme?
So sieht es aus. Man sieht einfach nur die Ahnungslosigkeit, mit der da formuliert wurde. Natürlich hat der Gesetzgeber im Nachhinein versucht, naja, wir schreiben da mal eine Begründung, da steht drin, dass wir es eigentlich gar nicht so meinen. Aber der Wortlaut ist bei uns nun mal immer noch entscheidend. Wir sind ja nun mal ein Rechtssystem, wo wir nach Paragraphen gehen. Und wenn man sich das durchliest, ist genau das der Fall. Man braucht bis zwei Stunden zu warten, und dann hat man beliebig viele Schadprogramme auf seinem Rechner.
Also wir sollten vielleicht noch mal das eine Beispiel nennen, warum wir den Paragraph handwerklich schlecht finden.
Gib mir bitte, bevor du weitermachst, hätte ich gerne fünf Sekunden Zeit, weil wir müssen nämlich sagen, wie spät es ist um 11. Und eine heiße Diskussion entspannt sich um den sogenannten HK-Paragraphen 202c Strafgesetzbuch, Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Teil 137 mit Konz, mit Fefe, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Rüdiger, das war ein hervorragender Anstoß für die Diskussion. Du siehst, wir kommen vom hundertsten zum tausendsten und machen gleich weiter dir einen schönen Abend noch. Hallo Sven, guten Abend.
Ja, abendschön. Hallo.
Hallo Herr.
Und zwar habe ich folgende Frage oder Andi. Und zwar sind ja etliche Programme vorher schon entstanden, sag ich mal, durch Windows schon alleine Betriebssysteme. Sind die denn jetzt auch alle strafbar?
Gute Frage.
Also du meinst jetzt von früher ein Windows-System, also gar nicht mehr so aktuelle?
Ja generell von XP. Wir können ja die ganze Zeit nehmen, sag ich mal. Da sind ja etliche Programme drauf, die man nehmen könnte. Von Hyperterminal angefangen, über Tellnet, die du schon sagst oder sonst was. Das ist ja eigentlich letztendlich doch alles strafbar.
Na ja klar, ist ja eigentlich nicht anders als bei den Beispielen davor. Also wenn es einen Zweck hat, der eben die Begehung von den Straftaten, also aufspähen und abfangen von Daten hat, dann wirst du betroffen.
Welche Beispiele für eine Strafverfolgung oder für eine Verfolgung solcher Hacker-Tools oder Suche solcher Hacker-Tools gibt es denn aus der Vergangenheitsgesetz? Gibt es seit einem Jahr? Wir versuchen hier gerade zusammen zu tragen, wo die Probleme auftauchen. Mein Mail-Inbox oder einfach nur ein Windows XP oder so. Gibt es da Beispiele aus der Vergangenheit, wo irgendwo gekloppt wurde und gesagt wurde, wir hätten gerne mal ihren Rechner gesehen?
Ja, ach so, wenn jetzt der Eindruck vermittelt wurde, dass es vorher gar keine Regelung gab, so ist das natürlich falsch. Wir haben ja jetzt nur eine neue Regelung. Es ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass wir auch schon früher eine wirkungsvolle Möglichkeit der Bestrafung von Computerkriminalität hatten. Natürlich. Also auch schon früher war natürlich das Ausspähen und Abfangen von Daten untersagt und mit Strafe bedroht. Deshalb argumentieren wir auch gerade, eigentlich könnte man den 202c weglassen. Nichts würde sich ändern.
Die Rechtsgrundlage bleibt dieselbe.
Na klar, weil also mit Abfangen und mit Ausspähen...
Das ist auch schon 202 übrigens. Also 202a und 202b gibt es auch. Da gibt es übrigens eine lustige Anekdote zu zur Clubgründung. Also wir erzählen uns manchmal, dass der Club bei der Schaffung von Paragraph 202 vor der Auswahl stand, als kriminelle Vereinigung oder als eingetragener Verein weiterzuarbeiten. Und dann haben wir halt den Verein gewählt. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen apokriffisch. Aber ich meine, ja, der Hackertool-Paragraph ist schon echt alt. Und das ist im Moment schon, also was heißt im Moment schon, vor dem 202c so gewesen, dass der Angriff auf den PC verboten war. Aber jetzt ist quasi schon das davor verboten. Jetzt möchten sie quasi die Vorbereitungshandlung verbieten und kriegen keine gute Definition dafür hin und sagen deswegen der Besitz von einem Tool.
Aber wenn das Gesetz so gelöchrig und so schwammig ist, wie ist es dann durchgegangen?
Naja, wir haben in der Veröffentlichung schon mal versucht zu erklären. So eine richtig gute Antwort haben wir nicht drauf. Meine persönliche Vermutung ist schlicht, dass ein gewisserzeitlicher Druck hinter war, weil eben die Cybercrime Convention umgesetzt werden musste und dass sie vom Tisch haben wollten. Auch, dass natürlich Teile der Mitglieder des Rechtsausschusses die technischen Details nicht durchschaut haben. Und dann kommt dazu, dass im Bundestag ja heute nicht mehr wirklich nach Sachlage entschieden wird, sondern nach Fraktionszwang. Und mir hat sich im Rechtsausschuss die... Eigentlich hat sich bei mir die Meinung aufgedrängt, dass vorher schon klar war. Lass sie mal erzählen, die Experten hier. Wir haben eigentlich schon beschlossen, dass es durchgeht. Augen zu und durch. Und da schreiben wir halt noch eine komische Begründung dran, die so ein bisschen relativiert. So war mein Eindruck. Man kann das anders sehen. Wir haben ja vorhin auch schon darüber gesprochen. Meine persönliche Meinung ist, dass da einfach auch wenig Interesse daran war und dass die Probleme, die da auf uns zukommen, überhaupt nicht gesehen wurden.
Diese ganze Diskussion, die wir jetzt hier auch führen und die viele Experten führen, Felix hat vorhin auch von BSI erzählt, die quasi eine eigene Bundesbehörde oder jemand, der für eine Bundesbehörde arbeitet, die selbst sagen, das Gesetz betrifft uns dann hier auch. Also im Haus würde es Probleme geben. Gibt es da irgendwelche Reaktionen auf den, wir werden es verändern oder wir werden es zurücknehmen? Oder ist das Gesetz jetzt da und bleibt es?
Na ja, es gab schon, als das in Kraft trat, oder kurz vor dem Krafttreten am 11. August letzten Jahres, gab es schon eine Menge Stellungnahmen. Das heißt, so die offiziellen Verbände wie die Bitkom oder der Eco-Verband, also die jetzt industrienah sind, die haben sich dann geäußert. Natürlich, klar, da gab es Widerstand. Es gab auch Firmen jetzt aus dem IT-Security-Bereich, die sich einzeln dazu geäußert haben und auch noch mal teilweise Stellungnahmen abgegeben haben. Eigentlich haben alle so ein bisschen erwartet, wann kommt der Erste, der die Befassungsbeschwerde macht. Die ist ja tatsächlich auch schon im Oktober geschrieben worden. Das heißt, relativ schnell nach dem Gesetz haben sich dann Leute an den Anwalt gewandt und versucht, Befassungsbeschwerde einzulegen. Und jetzt, momentan, haben wir ja sogar noch eine zweite Befassungsbeschwerde, die kommt aus dem universitären Bereich, wo einfach die Einschränkung der Lehre da auch noch mal möglichst angegriffen wird von dem Beschwerdeführer.
Weil, was du vorhin auch schon erzählt hast, dass an Universitäten gar nicht mehr unterrichtet werden kann, Leute gar nicht mehr ausgebildet werden können.
Das ist aber nicht nur Uni. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch eine Menge Zuschriften beim CCC. Wir kriegen immer so allerhand Mails, meistens ziemlich kritische zu Sachen, zu denen wir uns äußern. Und da war es besonders der Berufsausbildungsbereich, dass eben Berufsschüler, die irgendeine Form von Fachinformatiker werden, dass sie etwa von ihren Lehrenden dann gesagt bekommen, also früher haben wir hier noch praktisch Übungen gemacht, aber jetzt sagen wir, dass ihr euch ja irgendwie an eurer Freizeit aneignet, oder besser noch gar nicht, denn ihr macht euch ja da stafbar. Das hören wir von den jungen Berufsausbildenden. Das hören wir öfter.
Ja, wir können auch mal kurz erzählen. Also wir reden ja auch gelegentlich mit Politikern.
Warte mal, lass mich kurz mit Sven fragen, ob damit seine Frage beantwortet ist. Sven, bist du noch da?
Ja, ich bin noch da und meine Frage ist, dass man so weit beantwortet. Und ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin gelernter IT-Systemaktueuriker.
Du hast den Nullschuld. Was bist du gelernter?
IT-Systemaktueuriker.
Ah, Glückwunsch.
Hast du denn bei dir in der Lehre irgendwie betroffen oder ist das schon länger her?
Nee, ich habe jetzt auch frisch ausgelernt und ich bin davon nicht betroffen, muss ich sagen. In unserem Beruf hat man doch vieles gemacht, was nicht legal war. Aber das war halt alles gut am Zwischen. Da ist es aber normal, denke ich mal.
Und meinst du, das bleibt so? Habt ihr darüber gesprochen?
Nicht wirklich darüber gesprochen und ich denke mal, das bleibt auf jeden Fall so, weil die Lehrer sind alles ältere Lehrer. Die haben doch alles mit, sag ich mal, irgendwelchen älteren Programmen zu tun gehabt. Und wir jungen Schüler, sag ich mal, haben dann die neuen Programme mit eingefügt und somit haben wir uns irgendwo zusammen gewonnen und dadurch hat das genau kommuniziert.
Findest du das doch okay so oder denkst du manchmal, da wird kriminellen Aktivitäten vielleicht Vorschub geleistet?
Ah, ich denke mal, das ist okay. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass die Sätze vielleicht blöd sind in meinen Augen. Und dass wir irgendwie setzen, was die Politiker irgendwie gemacht haben, weil sie das machen wollten. Und ja, ich denke, das wird so weiterhin bleiben, auf jeden Fall.
Wärst du denn froh, wenn das Fassungsgericht in Karlsruhe sagt, ach nö, wollen wir nicht, das ist verpassungswidrig?
Ja, wir setzen sich, das ist ideal. Ich mache trotzdem...
Die ist ideal, deine Ausbildung ist jetzt noch durch.
Genau, und die können wir voll durch, die durch den weiteren machen werden, denke ich mal.
Ja, aber Sekunde, du willst ja erst in dem Beruf arbeiten, nicht wahr?
Ja.
Na ja, und wenn du mal in eine größere Firma gehst, dann hast du da auch eine Rechtsabteilung im Nacken, das ist dir schon klar, oder?
Ich mache jetzt zwar etwas anderes, erst mal eine Weile, aber es ist schon klar, aber irgendwo denke ich mal, ich war in einer kleineren Firma mit 20-25 Mann, und da haben wir trotzdem weiterhin so gemacht. Du musst es ja irgendwo machen, den Kunden, du musst ja die Kunden halten. Wenn du mal sagst, das geht nicht und so weiter, und wir können das nicht, warum setzt ihr, dann suchen sich irgendwelche anderen, die das können.
Deutschlands Computerexperten, eine Horde Straftäter.
Ja, wir stehen alle mit einem Bein im Knast. Ja, also wir reden ja schon mit Politikern gelegentlich, und wir fragen natürlich auch, wie kommt es, dass so ein Gesetz durchkommt. Und was wir da häufig hören, ist, naja, es ist ja noch keiner im Knast deswegen.
Und was ist eigentlich ein Browser?
Also das System funktioniert, ja gut, das kommt auch, aber der Zirkelschluss ist an der Stelle perfekt, denn die sagen sozusagen, naja, es ist ja noch keiner zu Unrecht verhaftet worden, also funktioniert ja unser System, und dann können wir das Gesetz auch lassen. Das heißt, wir haben ein Gesetz, das im Grunde Latent halb Deutschland im Knast stellt. Ja, aber das macht ja nichts, weil die Richter machen das bisher nicht. Also quasi völlig unglaublich.
Aber die Richter entscheiden nicht, weil die Rechtslage unklar ist, und sie fällen keine Entscheidung, und die Rechtslage bleibt unklar, weil die Richter keine Entscheidung fällen. Das Ding dreht sich jetzt immer um sich selber.
Genau, so dreht sich das um sich selber. Und normalerweise macht man aus genau diesem Grund, also was heißt man, aber die Amerikaner machen das so, dass sie ein Gesetz erst mal nur für ein Jahr erlassen. Also das gibt es ja auch selten.
Gibt's.
Aber das gibt's. Und das heißt, das Gesetz, wenn es nach einem Jahr nicht wieder bestätigt wird, ist es automatisch wieder weg.
Hat quasi einen Verfallsdatum.
Genau.
Und das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Weil das heißt, wenn sich zeigt, dass wir das nie gebraucht haben, das Gesetz, dann können wir es auch wieder wegschmeißen. Find ich eine gute Sache.
Ein Gesetzbuch mit Löschroutieren.
Entschuldigung, meine Herren. Da möchte ich immer mal einwenden, dass es eigentlich so ist, dass der Gesetzgeber vorab prüfen muss, ob dieses Gesetz Sinn macht. Er muss es sinnvoll begründen. Es ist nicht so, dass... Man ist jetzt zwar daran gewöhnt, dass wir so professionelle, ich sag mal, auf Deutsch zu sagen, Gesetzesverkacke haben und dass viele Gesetze gekippt werden. Aber eigentlich müsste unser verfassungsgebender Organ und gesetzgebender Organ eben der Bundestag vorher prüfen, ob ein Gesetz okay ist. Also fangen wir nicht an, nur weil die da gerade keine guten Gesetze machen, da die Standards nach unten zu setzen.
Nein, so was ist doch nicht gemeint. Aber wir könnten zumindest diesen Notanker, den finde ich schon an sich eine gute Idee. Also das ist auch so ein Trend in der Rangehensweise von Programmieren, Extreme Programming, da sagt man, Fehler werden halt gemacht. Und dann müssen wir eben dafür sorgen, dass sie korrigiert werden. Gut, bei Gesetzen sollte es nicht so sein.
Aber jetzt stell dir bitte vor...
Ladies and Gentlemen, bevor wir jetzt hier über die Gesetzgebung in Deutschland an sich diskutieren, schlage ich vor, wir atmen alle drei Minuten durch, hören die Co-Letment No Government und dann diskutieren wir mit euch weiter unter 0331 70 97 110 über Paragraph 202 Strafgesetzbuch, den Hacker Paragraphen im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Schnieke Musik hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Nicolette, No Government. Die Frau kennt ihr vielleicht von einigen Massive Attack Platten. Wir haben es gleich viertel zwölf. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit Fefe, mit Konz. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir telefonieren und reden und diskutieren mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Und es geht um den ominösen Hacker- Paragraphen. Wir haben in der letzten Stunde schon mit mehreren Beispielen erwähnt, warum dieser Paragraph ziemlicher Mumpitz ist und warum dieses Gesetz auf so dünnem Eis steht. Der nächste am Telefon ist Johannes, der uns ordentlich die Leviten lesen will. Wir haben nämlich Unsinn erzählt. Hallo, Johannes.
Die ganze Backup-Geschichte ist schon ein bisschen länger her, als ihr behauptet habt, dass ältere Backup für einzuspielen, auf denen diese Tools vorhanden sind, auch nicht so ganz legal wäre oder dass man damit Probleme bekommen könnte. Es nicht wirklich war, weil der Besitz an sich, der Hacker-Tools, wollte ich nur ganz kurz berichtigen, selber nicht illegal ist. Also wenn, ich weiß nicht, dass der 202c vor einem Jahr ungefähr in Kraft getreten muss, wenn die Backups älter als ein Jahr sind.
Na ja, die Frage ist, also du hast Recht, der Besitz ist nicht verboten, aber dass sich verschaffen ist verboten. Wenn du dir jetzt ein Tape aus dem Schrank holst von 1980 und holst dir da ein Telnet runter, oder was weiß ich, ein Angriffstool, dann könnte man ja argumentieren, dass es sich verschaffen ist. Weil du hast es vorher nicht auf deinem Rechner gehabt, aber danach hast du es auf dem Rechner.
Aber ich habe es besessen.
Na ja, aber in einer Form, die du nicht ausführen konntest vorher.
Verschaffen ist, dass ich den Besitz erschaffe. Also jetzt nicht physikalisch das Ding aus dem Schrank holen.
Na ja, pass mal auf, die Linie ist nicht so einfach. Es gab mal vor vielen Jahren eine CD zu kaufen mit lauter verschlüsselten Programmen drauf und da hat man dann eins gekauft und dann haben die einem den Key zugeschickt und damit hat man das entschlüsselt. Und da hätte man genauso argumentieren können mit dem Backup jetzt. Wieso war doch in meinem Besitz? Also das ist nicht so einfach, wie du es hier gerade machst. Da kann man lange und ausgiebig drüber streiten.
Nein, nein, also ich würde schon sagen, dass du im Wesentlichen Recht hast. Man kann sich natürlich ein paar Spezialfälle kreieren, wo Besitz nicht so ganz klar ist, also wo der Unterschied zwischen zugänglich machen, verschaffen und Besitz nicht klar ist. Im Wesentlichen würde ich schon sagen, das stimmt, weil im Gesetz steht auch nicht besitzen, sondern eben nur herstellen, sich verschaffen, verkaufen, überlassen, verbreiten oder zugänglich machen. Und insofern hast du dem Wortlaut nach auf jeden Fall recht.
Das heißt, wenn die IT-Firma, die Sicherheitsfirma ein Giftschrank hat, wo all die bösen, bösen Viren drin sind, besitzen sie sie nur und damit kann ihnen noch keiner was.
Wenn sie sie nicht hergestellt haben.
Und sich auch nicht verschafft haben, was ja ein bisschen schwierig in der Beweislage dann wahrscheinlich sein wird.
Verwachtmeister, die waren einfach da.
Die haben da halt, die hat Captain Kirk runtergebeamt.
Das ist wie mit den Filmen nachts, die man dann morgens auf der Festplatte findet. Die sind einfach da.
Du hast Filme auf der Festplatte?
Ja, kennst du das nicht, dass du manchmal morgens irgendwie den Computer aufklappst und wieder neue Filme da?
Ich hab immer nur Kaffeetassen-Ränder auf der Festplatte.
Also Johannes, wir wollen uns natürlich für den Hinweis bedanken. Also wenn wir dir ein bisschen flapsig ausgedrückt haben, ich denke schon, dass du zumindest, was den Wortlaut betrifft, auf jeden Fall recht hast und in vielen Details wohl auch und nur in einigen Spezialfällen das nicht so ganz klar wäre.
Also nur generell, solange die Dinge eben älter sind, hat man da ein Jahr Sinn, de facto anscheinend nicht zu befrechten.
Aber wenn du deinen Backup outgesourct hast und du rufst jetzt die Firma an, bring mir doch mal das Tape von 2004.
Dann haben die ein Problem, weil sonst...
Na ja, aber ich meine, da ist ein Problem, würde ich damit sagen. Ist ja wurscht.
Fühlst du dich denn sonst irgendwie betroffen? Also was hältst du denn von den Paragraphen so?
Ja gut, dass es schmarrn ist, dann muss man eigentlich nicht drüber reden.
Also du würdest dich auch freuen, wenn Karlsruhe sagt, auch nö.
Naja, selber betroffen bin ich es noch nicht wirklich, aber das kommt dann spätestens im Vertiefungsstudium, denke ich.
Dann wünschen wir dir viel Glück, einen wunderbaren Sommer und immer eine weiße Weste.
Nicht Glück, Erfolg wünschen wir.
Danke Johannes, tschüss. Der nächste am Telefon ist Konstantin, der einen sehr interessanten Einwurf hat. Hallo Konstantin.
Ja hallo. Wenn es jetzt legal ist, die Dinger zu besitzen, was ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Virus zugeschickt kriege oder irgendeine Software, die sich selbstständig verbreitet und weiterschickt? Führt die sich ja gleichzeitig auch aus?
Du, ohne dein Zutun?
Naja, ich muss ja irgendwas aufrufen, auspasehen, dass die sich ausführt, aber sie führt sich aus. Und ich bin ja im Grunde dann schuld daran und mache mich ja damit strafbar, obwohl ich gar nichts davon wusste.
Meinst du jetzt die Verbreitung, also dass du sie verbreitest?
Naja, da bist du auf jeden Fall dran, wenn die Software, wenn es ein Virus ist, und der verkopiert sich weiter an andere Leute. Also theoretisch ja, in der Praxis ist es so, dass wir das ja schon länger haben, dass Viren praktisch verboten sind, dass sind ja schon Leute für belangt worden. Allerdings gibt es auch den Gegenfall, und der ist deutlich häufiger in der Rechtsprechung, dass Leute aus Sachen rauskommen, weil sie sagen, den habe ich aber nicht installiert, sondern der hat sich von alleine installiert. Also es gab auch sogar jemanden, der aus einem Kinderporno-Fall rausgekommen ist, mit der Begründung, dass habe ich ein Virus installiert. Der hätte das gedownloadet, und das wäre es gar nicht gewesen. Also im Zweifelsfall, wenn der Richter verstehen kann, dass du die Software nicht installiert hast, würde ich mir privat jetzt keine Sorgen machen, aber das ist durchaus ein Spannungsfeld, da würde ich dir Recht geben.
Und wie ist das in sich, wenn ich da ein Skript in meinen Web 3.0 Dienst eintippe, ist das dann schon ein Programm, was ich erzeugt habe, dadurch, dass ich da alles Mögliche weiter arbeite.
Kannst du mal bitte mit einem konkreten Beispiel das Ganze unterbauen?
Naja, man muss sich schon vergegenwärtigen, dass Angriffssoftware jetzt nicht immer große Software ist, sondern dass so ein Exploit, und wir haben beispielhaft einen in unserer Stellungnahme, auch schon mal ein Einzeiler sein kann. Also was heißt, ein Angriffstool muss nicht eben lang und breit sein und kann durchaus einen kleinen Skript schon hergeben, durchaus.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich auch den Fall gesehen, dass ich festgestellt habe, dass es möglich ist, bei einem System bei uns in der Nähe, also hier aus Görlitz, gibt es so einen Web 2.0-Dienst. Und da war es möglich, Skript auszuführen per Nachrichten. Und da habe ich dann mit Minden mal geschrieben, der hat es erst noch mal im Jahr dann gefixt, aber da habe ich auch so ein Problem gesehen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel eigentlich.
Ja, und Kettenmails sind ja an sich auch so eine Sache.
Ja, da haben wir auch schon vorhin beim Abendessen darüber diskutiert, ob man nicht auch ein Nigeria-Scam als Angriffssoftware werten kann. Die hackt dann zwar nicht den Rechner, sondern das Hirn, den User. Aber gut, das ist jetzt natürlich nicht gemeint mit dem Gesetz. Und da wird wahrscheinlich auch der Richter sagen, nein.
Ja, dafür wurde doch mal einer verhaftet, weil er halt übers Telefon die Passwörter herausgekriegt hat.
Ja, wo wir bei Passwörtern waren, da haben wir auch noch einen wichtigen Punkt, den wir noch erwähnen wollten.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das mitbekommen haben, aber es gab ja doch eine ziemlich schwere Sicherheitslücke bei der Linienungsdistribution Debiagen. Und da haben wir mal ein Beispiel, wo es sich nicht um den Zweck von Software dreht, sondern um den anderen Fall, der in dem Paragraphen 202c drin ist, nämlich Passwortliste.
Wer eine Straftat vorbereitet, indem er Passwörter herstellt oder zugänglich macht?
Also, da muss ich auch eine kleine Anekdote erzählen aus dem Ausschuss, in dem er saß.
Warte mal, wir verabschieden erst einmal Konstantin in die Nacht. Das war ein großartiger Eingriff.
Ich wollte mal sagen, dass an sich wahrscheinlich der Computerbesitz strafbar ist und die Adresse...
Oh man, die Idee...
Ja, der Internet ist strafbar, Denken ist strafbar, gute Musik hören ist strafbar und nach 11 bei Fritz anrufen ist noch nicht strafbar.
Und die Adresseile im Browser oder sowieso der Browser ist ja auch ein Hacker-Tour.
Außer du gibst eine lange Telefonnummer ein. Kannst ja auch vielleicht irgendwas mit hacken.
Oder Nutzernamen von Telekom oder sowas.
Nur mit Telepartie anrufen.
So jung und schon so kriminell.
Ich wohne in einem Opal-Ghetto, da gibt es kein Internet.
So jetzt aber. Passwörter.
Genau, also das ist so die Formulierung, die du da vorgelesen hast, die ist auf vielen anderen aufgefallen und ich saß also in diesem Ausschuss im Bundestag und habe also eigentlich meine Argumente bringen wollen und das war natürlich auf meiner Liste drauf. Das Herstellen von Passwortlisten, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Was ist eine Passwortliste?
Ja, das ist totaler Mumpitz. Also ich meine, was damit gemeint ist, ist wahrscheinlich, dass es Passwortcracker gibt, also Programme, die einfach ganz viele Passwörter ausprobieren, indem sie einfach ein Wörterbuch nehmen und ein bisschen narrieren und damit halt versuchen aus einem Hashtag, so speichert man heute Passwörter aus, das Passwort zu rekonstruieren. Also das ist eine Art von Angriffsstoffware und das hat das Gesetz wahrscheinlich gemeint. Aber was da steht, ist eben was anderes. Da steht das Herstellen an der Passwortliste und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen Zettel nehme und da, sagen wir mal, meine Einkaufsliste raufschreibe, dann weiß doch keiner, ob das Passwörter sind oder nicht. Das heißt, theoretisch könnten jetzt Richter kommen und sagen, das sieht mir aus wie eine Passwortliste. Brot, Milch, Möhtüten, Herr Leitner. Ich hatte das fest vor in diesem Ausschuss anzusprechen und war der Dritte an der Reihe in der Liste. Alle vor mir haben das angesprochen und haben gesagt, das Schönste war, dass die Industrievertreter, die haben es versucht diplomatisch zu machen. Also ich bin ja eher so ein Typ, ich stelle mich hin und sage, das ist Blödsinn, das können sie so nicht machen. Das gibt keinen Sinn. Aber die Industrievertreter haben gesagt, das sieht schlecht für die gesetzgebende Instanz aus in unserem Lande, wenn ein Gesetz diese Formulierung fälschlicherweise enthält. Und dann könnte das Volk ihnen die Kompetenz absprechen.
Die sind einfach so seriös.
Ja, die sind halt seriöser, als ich das gerade schon sage.
So, aber nochmal, die Erstellung einer Passwortliste, mein Mozilla Browser macht nichts anderes, außer mich zu fragen, soll ich das Passwort speichern? Und ich sage, ja, mach mal. Ich mache das nämlich nicht. Und dann gibt es irgendwo eine Liste, wo ich sage, ah, das sind alle meine Passworte. Damit ist mein Mozilla strafbar oder ecke?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein grenzwertiges Beispiel ist. Bei dem Debian-Beispiel sieht man es ein bisschen besser. Denn um dieses Problem zu lösen, wenn man sich jetzt eine neue Debian holt, also diese Linux-Distribution, dann kriegt man halt diese Passwortliste mit, um zu checken, ob man irgendwelche Keys hat, die man nicht mehr benutzen sollte, weil sie unsicher sind. Das heißt, es hat eine Liste, eine 5-stellige Anzahl von Schlüsseln, die dann mitgeliefert wird. Man bekommt die also. Und das ist eindeutig eine Passwortliste, die man aber auch gleichzeitig dazu benutzen kann, um anzugreifende Computer auswendig zu machen. Etwa Banken oder Online-Shops kann man natürlich damit tun. Da kann sich aber erstmal der Benutzer auch nicht wehren, denn das ist eine ganz klassische sogenannte Dual-Use-Tool. Also diese Passwortliste kann eben zu einem guten Bildenzweck verwendet werden.
Also es gibt sogar noch ältere Beispiele. Es ist seit, weiß ich nicht, 20 Jahren üblich unter Unix, wenn man sein Passwort ändert, dass das Passwortender-Programm in einer Datenbank nachguckt, ob dieses Passwort leicht zu raten ist oder nicht. Und dazu gehört unter anderem eben auch, dass der in einer Wörterliste nachguckt, ob das direkt ein Wort aus einem Wörterbuch ist.
Das ist einfach um die Qualität zu sichern, damit man den User dazu zwingt.
Das gibt es nicht nur unter Unix, es gibt es in ganz vielen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber unter Unix ist es tatsächlich eine Textdatei, wo einfach die Passwörter drin stehen. Und damit ist völlig klar, das ist eine Passwortliste. Und die hat jemand erstellt und ich habe sie mir beschafft, indem ich Unix installiert habe. Und das ist strafbar.
Also das ist für mich auch noch bei vielen anderen Beispielen sichtbar. Ich habe zum Beispiel große Passwortlisten, die ich sammle, weil ich mich mit der Sicherheit von Passworten befasse. Ich habe zum Beispiel etwa mal, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das im Radio sagen darf, oder ob ich den schönen Strafband bin.
Ich mache mal kurz dein Mikrofon.
Ich habe zum Beispiel die Gesamtliste der User-Accounts und Passworte von MySpace. Denn die sind ja mehrfach gehackt worden, und die findet sich dann im Netz. Und weil es eine große Liste ist von vielen Millionen Passwörtern, kann man die sehr gut analysieren, hinsichtlich der Qualität der Passwörter.
Alles für die Wissenschaft. Das geht hier nicht ums Hacken.
Kronz musste umziehen, weil diese 400 Tonnen Papier irgendwo hinmuss.
Ja, ich habe die ja nicht ausgedruckt. Also das ist natürlich eine große Textdatei. Und natürlich darf ich die eigentlich nicht mehr haben. Denn klar, die kann man natürlich auch zu bösen Zwecken verwenden.
Na, eigentlich durftest du die vorher schon nicht haben. Das ist nämlich Ausspähen von Daten.
Nein, nein, ich habe sie nicht ausspäht. Ich habe mir die Datei runtergeladen.
Na, das kannst du ja mal nachweisen dann im Einfluss.
Okay, ich sehe die Problematik. Aber ich habe natürlich keine Passwerte ausgespäht. Ich habe mir nur die Textdatei geladen.
Wenn Sie da Fragen haben, dann rufen Sie einfach an 0331 70 97 110.
Gibt es hier eigentlich einen Hinterausgang?
Ja, da ist eine Schranke, wie du siehst. Zurück zum Thema. Der nächste am Telefon ist Martin. Hallo Martin, guten Abend. Martin, bist du noch da? Moment.
Du hast das Radio noch an, oder?
Genau, ich hatte das Radio noch an.
Wir haben dich ein bisschen überfahren. Wir haben dir nicht gesagt, dass du gleich dran bist. Aber jetzt bist du dran. Martin, grüß dich. Wie hast du deinen Mittwoch bis Langfeier gebracht? Wir haben ein bisschen geplenkelt, dass wir wieder reinkommen.
Was habe ich heute gemacht? Ich bin erst mal ausgeschlafen.
Also du bist ein Ferienmensch gerade.
Ja, genau.
Und keine Hackertour ist zwischendurch eingestellt?
Nein, das geht ja gerade nicht. Ich bin ja im Urlaub segeln.
Ach, hast du den Rechner nicht bei?
Aber du bist jetzt nicht 200 Seemeilen nördlich von Kaporn und rufst uns vom Satellitentelefon an und hast schon 500 Dollar verbaraten? Nein.
Nein, bin ich nicht. Ich bin in Mecklenburg.
So, jetzt deine Frage.
Also meine Frage wäre jetzt gewesen, ob XFire auch so ein Angriffstool ist.
Was ist XFire?
XFire ist Software für Spiele. Also es geht mir jetzt ja hauptsächlich um die Studiengänge oder Arbeit oder so. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Spiel im Internet spielt, kann man Programme XFire installieren, so. Und da kann man jetzt sehen, wie lange jemand zum Beispiel im Internet war und dieses und jenes Spiel gespielt hat. Und andere können das bei dir auch sehen. Und gleichzeitig überprüft dieses Programm immer wieder, ob dein Spiel auch original ist. So ist das jetzt auch ein Angriffstool?
Nee, du hast ja da, du riechst jetzt ja keinen Schaden an. Also das wäre höchstens Ausspähen von Daten, wenn da nicht sowieso eine Schnittstelle wäre, um an diese Informationen ranzukommen. Und die existiert ja offensichtlich. Also da würde ich mir jetzt keine Sorgen machen.
Wie stellst du dir denn den Angriff vor? Also wie würdest du damit einen Angriff vorbereiten können?
Also es gibt ja nur die Daten raus.
Na, Ausspähen von Daten ist schon auch ein Angriff. Also in dem Gesetz. Aber das würde ich jetzt hier nicht so deuten wollen.
Ist diese Sorge um die mögliche Straftat, die du da begangen hast, auch ein Grund dafür, dass du dich gerade auf einem Segelboot...
Nein, das ist kein Grund. Das ist einfach nur der jährliche Urlaub.
Verstehe. Okay, also die Frage nochmal ganz konkret beantwortet. Felix, ist X-Fire ein Angriffstool?
Ich würde sagen nein.
Also ich würde auch sagen nein.
Ja, dann leihenlos, Schiff ahoi und nicht über die Boi fahren. Tschüss Martin. Wie mache ich die Nachrichten? Und danach geht es weiter im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Es geht um den Hacker-Paragraphen, Paragraph 202c, Strafgesetzbuch, der sagt, wer Straftaten vorbereitet, indem er Passwörter oder Sicherheitscodes oder Programme herstellt oder zugänglich macht, geht in den Bau. Und zwar für ein Jahr oder es gibt eine Geldstrafe. Und wir sind gerade dabei, diese Formulierung mal zu überprüfen und anhand von Beispielen zu belegen, dass das alles auf sehr, sehr, sehr wackeligen Füßen steht. Mehr dazu gleich hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Ich werde jetzt einen punktgenauen 30-Sekunden-Aufsager hier einsprechen, der mein Programm in einem goldenen Licht dastehen lassen wird.
Fritz präsentiert...
Wasch live. Ich selber ture wieder, die Show heißt bestuhlt. Und nur die ganz, ganz, ganz dämlichen werden nicht erkennen, wie feinsinnig doppeldeutig dieser Titel ist.
Tommy Worsch, live und auf Tour in Berlin und Brandenburg.
Bestuhlt.
Unsere Comedy-Tour 2008 ist eine magische Reise an die Grenzen des menschlichen Verstandes und darüber hinaus.
Wann, wo, wieso, weshalb und warum sowas überhaupt nötig ist.
So, das war jetzt auch wirklich fein. Das könnt ihr einfach ungeschnitten. Wir senden vielen Dank. Nachrichten.
Mit Keitern, natürlich.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die Berliner Regelung zum Rauchverbot in der Gastronomie gekippt. Nach dem Urteil ist Rauchen in Einraumkneipen vorerst unter Auflagen wieder erlaubt. Die Richter sahen die Betroffenen wirte benachteiligt gegenüber den Betreibern größerer Gaststätten, in denen in abgetrennten Räumen geraucht werden darf. Bis Ende 2009 muss das Gesetz geändert werden. Entweder gibt es dann Ausnahmeregelungen für alle oder ein allgemeines Rauchverbot. Verbraucher sollen in Zukunft besser vor unerwünschten Werbeanrufen geschützt werden. Das Bundeskabinett hat heute einen entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf beschlossen. Bei unerlaubter Telefonwerbung drohen Firmen demnach bis zu 50.000 Euro Strafe. Außerdem müssen Callcenter, die ihre Rufnummer unterdrücken, bis zu 10.000 Euro zahlen. Bundestag und Bundesrat müssen noch zustimmen. Chinas Zensur von Internetseiten bei den Olympischen Spielen ist weltweit auf scharfe Proteste gestoßen. US-Präsident Bush forderte China auf, das Internet ohne Beschränkungen freizugeben. Der Vorsitzende des Sportausschusses im Bundestag, Dankhart, ist dafür, die weltweite Fernsehübertragung der Eröffnungsspiele abzusagen, wenn China nicht einlenke. Der CDU-Außenpolitiker Polenz sagte, dass die Hardliner im chinesischen Politbüro sich bestätigt fühlen, wenn die Zensur hingenommen werde. Der Berliner SPD-Chef Müller will den Anstieg der Mieten in Berlin dämpfen. Müller sagte der Online-Ausgabe der Berliner Morgenpost, dass die soziale Mischung erhalten werden solle. So solle Mietspiegel 2009 die Spanne für Erhöhungen eingeschränkt und neue Kriterien wie Verkehrslärm und Energiebedarf der Wohnungen aufgenommen werden. Israels Ministerpräsident Olmert hat seinen Rücktritt angekündigt. Er erklärte am Abend, dass er sich bei der Wahl im September nicht mehr um den Vorsitz der regierenden Kadima-Partei bewerben will. Er stelle dann auch nicht mehr als Regierungschef bereit. Olmert wird Bestechlichkeit vorgeworfen. Er bestreitet das. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, Potsdam-Bittenberg 20°C, Frankfurt-Kotbus-Angermünde 21°C, Neurupien 23°C und in Berlin sind es derzeit 19°C. Heute Nacht ist es nur wenig bewirkt und meist trocken, bei Tieswerten von bis zu 18°C. Morgen gibt es wieder richtiges Sommerwetter. Es gibt viel Sonne. Nur am Nachmittag kann es ein paar wenige Wolken geben und das bei Höchstwerten bis zu 32°C. Mit drei Meldungen auf der A100 Stadtrin Richtung Neukölln-Treptow zwischen Siemensdamm und Spandauer Damm. 1 km Stau. A105 Abzweig-Reinigendorf zwischen Kurt-Schumacher-Platz und Kreuz-Reinigendorf. Dorf ist in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Dort wird eine Brücke abgerissen. Und auf der A111 Stadtautobahn, Stadteinwehr zwischen Heckerdamm und Dreieck Charlottenburg, dort ist gesperrt, auch dort wird gebaut. Sonst eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Dann Fritz in Berlin.
Und ihr seid in Chaosradio mit Tefe, mit Franz und mit Jakob Franz. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit über den sogenannten Hackerparagraphen zu diskutieren. Und es gibt noch ein paar Dinge, die wir dringend ansprechen müssen, bevor uns die entwickeln.
Ja, denn da ist uns noch ein besonders wichtiger Punkt, eigentlich den wir auch in der Stellungnahme schon ausgeführt haben. Da beziehen wir uns auf dieses neue Grundrecht. Die meisten werden sich vielleicht erinnern, es gab ja die Verhandlung über die Online-Durchsuchung, über das Verfassungsschutzgesetz in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Und da hatte ja Anfang des Jahres das Verfassungsgericht gesagt, okay, so ist das verfassungswidrig, aber wir schenken sozusagen den Bürgern gleich mal ein neues Grundrecht. Das hat ein bisschen sperrige Namen. Das heißt, das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Integrität und Vertraulichkeit von informationstechnischen Systemen. Und wir haben jetzt versucht, uns mal inhaltlich damit ausnahmzusetzen und dann eigentlich zu der Erkenntnis gekommen, wenn wir ein Grundrecht haben, dass unsere Computersysteme, die wir benutzen, integriert sind, dann brauchen wir auch gleichzeitig die Möglichkeit, dass wir sie noch testen können. Und wenn wir selber nicht können, weil wir eben die Fähigkeiten nicht haben, können wir natürlich auch davon ausgehen, dass wir Dienstlässe dafür eben mal uns kaufen können oder uns im Freundeskreis besorgen können.
Das heißt, um es einfacher zu formulieren, dieser Hacker-Paragraph torpediert gerade dieses Grundrecht auf sichere Computersysteme.
So sieht es aus, denn diese Integrität der Computersysteme wurde uns ja gewährleistet mit dem Grundrecht und auch da, also nicht nur im Bereich der Pressefreiheit, der Forschungsfreiheit, der Berufsfreiheit, sondern auch in Bezug auf unser neues Grundrecht, dieses sogenannte IT-Grundrecht, wie die jetzt viele Juristen sagen, ist da betroffen. Da sind wir fest überzeugt von.
Schwein im Raume?
Also haben wir uns auch sehr gefreut, dass sie uns ein neues Recht gegeben haben und dass wir das gleich anwenden konnten.
Die nächste Frage kommt von Lutz, der will nämlich wissen, ob Anti-Spy... Warte mal, danach reden wir mit Alex Konzi. Hallo Lutz. Hallo. Abend. Dieses Thema hatten wir vorhin schon mal, Anti-Spyware, also sozusagen ein Viren-Checker. Ist das auch ein Angriffstool?
Genau. Die Frage ist jetzt ganz speziell, weil ich hatte vor kurzem ein Tool, was sich irgendwie an Anti-Spy nannte und hat sich einfach auf meinen Rechner installiert oder irgendwie ist es auf meinen Rechner gekommen, ohne irgendeine Datei auf der Festplatte zu haben, also zumindest keine fündbare Datei.
Unsichtbar.
Hast du den Ruhken eingefangen?
Keine Ahnung. Also ich habe versucht, also ich habe neu gestartet, dann hat sich das immer wieder neu geladen und wollte mich auf irgendeine Senette verweisen, dass ich es doch freischalte und dann hat es irgendwann meinen Desktop gesperrt, wo die Uhrzeitstandstand alarm und unter dem Startordner alles gesperrt, wo ich auf die Festplatte zugreifen kann. Ich kam nur auch über abgesicherte Modus, Administraterkonto rein und war auch nicht zu finden, das Programm.
Das heißt, deine Daten wurden quasi in Geiselhaft genommen?
Genau, sozusagen.
Dann musst du dir mal eine richtige Anti-Spyware ziehen und im abgesicherten Modus ausführen. Aber können wir dir jetzt auch die Details hier nicht am Radio erzählen. Aber das ist tatsächlich, da hast du dir echt eine Mailware eingefangen.
Denn ich hatte nämlich auch ein paar Mal im abgesicherten Modus Anti-Viren-Programm durchlaufen lassen und hat auch nicht gefunden, komischerweise.
Ja, das ist halt eine eigene Kategorie. Das ist nicht wirklich ein Virus, sondern es ist auch Mailware. Das ist so die Oberkategorie. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eine Spyware, würde ich sagen. Ja, das ist ein üblicher Trick.
Also eine Spyware, was ich als Anti-Spyware ausgibt, sozusagen.
Genau, das ist ein üblicher Trick, dass irgendwelche Tools versuchen, dir zu suggerieren, du hättest ein Problem und du musst jetzt unbedingt die Vollversion kaufen, sonst ist dein Rechner kaputt. Ja, also das ist häufig, das gibt es häufiger. Und wenn du ein Antivirus nicht findest, kannst du ja mal beim Hersteller beschweren, oder?
Oder einfach einen anderen ausprobieren.
Also ich hab's immer versucht, zu schließen, aber das kam dann immer wieder.
Ja, wie gesagt, also der Tipp im Detail, den können wir jetzt natürlich per Fernwartung auch nicht machen, aber abgesicherten Modus starten, einfach mal was anderes probieren, vielleicht hast du da eine Chance oder aber den Alphanerd deinem Vertrauen fragen. Auf jeden Fall Daumen drücken und viel Glück, Lutz. Danke dir für den Anruf.
Na ja, ich meine nur, Spyware ist ja eine Sache, wo man immer sagen kann, na ja Gott, niemand will das. Und gerade so, du bist ein unbedarfter Benutzer, der von Spyware betroffen ist, das hat echt schon langsam ethische Probleme bei Computern. Spyware will genau niemanden. Ich frage mich, wer das immer überprogrammiert.
Ich glaube übrigens auch, dass Alex, der hier immer anruft, dass Alex auch Spyware ist, weil immer wenn ich Alex rannehmen will, ist er wieder weg. Alex, du kannst gerne nochmal anrufen.
Ja, wir interessieren uns sehr dafür, was du sagen wolltest.
Das weiß aber jetzt sonst noch keiner, deswegen klären wir das erst, wenn Alex anruft und wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Wir haben noch zwei, drei Punkte, die wir auch noch ansprechen wollten. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir hier Däumchen drehen.
Ein wichtiger Punkt, der uns als aktuelles Beispiel eingefallen ist, ist die Myfair-Sache. Wir haben vor wenigen Tagen gerade noch ein aktuelles Gerichtsurteil bekommen, denn es gibt diese Myfair-Ships, das ist mittlerweile sogar schon in der offiziellen Presse, also nicht nur in der Tech-Presse berichtet worden, die vielfach benutzt werden in Europa, meistens für Verkehrsbezahlsysteme, etwa in UK, also in Großbritannien oder in Holland. Und es hat sich bei uns auf dem letzten Kongress, im Dezember letzten Jahres, ein Forscherteam vorgestellt und hat eben gezeigt, dass die hackbar sind und unsicher. Und jetzt ist es dazu gekommen, dass der Hersteller, NXP, der hat sich hingestellt und wollte gerichtlich verhindern lassen, dass die Details dieses Hacks bekannt werden.
Weil dadurch, dass es gehackt wurde, ihr quasi Dinge gemacht habt, die offiziell, also was heißt das, offiziell, die strafbar sind.
Genau. Also die haben nicht ihr Problem fixen wollen, sondern haben halt gedacht, das ist billiger, wenn wir versuchen, die Details geheim zu halten.
Und da sieht man halt auch die Denkweise, die bei Herstellerfirmen von Software oder teilweise im Hardware, die da an den Tag gelegt werden. Das heißt, wir haben auch noch lange Zeit, wenn man jetzt mal so 10, 20 Jahre zurückgeht, gesehen, dass die Hersteller einfach Lücken, die existieren, verleugnen. Das heißt, es wird behauptet, die existieren nicht, aber sie seien nicht so wichtig.
Und solange keiner nachbrücken kann, dass es die gibt.
Genau.
Genau. Und deswegen gibt es überhaupt offene Exploits im Internet.
So sieht es aus.
Das ist historisch nämlich so gewachsen, dass die Hersteller einfach A sich geweigert haben, zuzugeben, dass es eine Lücke gibt. Und B wenn man ihnen nachgewiesen hat, dass es eine Lücke gibt, dann haben sie gesagt, ja ja, fixen wir und haben dann zwei Jahre darauf gesessen. Das passiert teilweise heute immer noch. Und der einzige Weg, was man da tun kann, ist eben, dass man einen Exploit veröffentlicht. Und dann ist quasi bewiesen öffentlich, dass da nicht nur Lücke ist, sondern dass die ausnutzbar ist. Und dann sehen sich die Firmen auch genötigt, mal einen Fix zu machen.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du so einen Exploit veröffentlicht, also wenn du in der Öffentlichkeit darstellst, wie man dieses System hacken kann, befällst du ja optimal unter diesen Paragraphen 203.
Genau. Also das kann man im Moment sehr gut sehen. Gerade heute war auf Heise die Meldung, dass Oracle einen Fix gemacht hat für einen Zero-Day. Das ist genau so ein Exploit, der im Zero-Day heißt, der ist noch nicht publiziert, also für eine Lücke, die vorher nicht bekannt war. Und den haben sie dann auch sofort gefixt. Und üblicherweise macht Oracle das so, dass sie alle viertel Jahre, glaube ich, einen Patch-Day machen, wo sie dann Patches raustun. Und das heißt, wenn man jetzt eine Lücke findet, dann ist die da wahrscheinlich schon jahrelang drin. Und Leute, die schon wussten, dass es die Lücke gab, bevor dieser Exploit veröffentlicht wird, das gibt es ja auch, die konnten das schon seit langem ausnutzen. Aber wenn es dann diesen Exploit gibt, dann ist es also quasi erstens bekannt, dass es ein Problem gibt. Und wenn jemand anderes guckt und nach Problemen sucht, kann es ja sein, dass er genau dieses Problem findet. Aber es gibt eben noch keinen Patch vom Hersteller. Und das machen viele Hersteller so und begründen es damit, dass Firmen ja gar nicht täglich patchen können. Und das ist ja Aufwand und bla bla. Aber in der Praxis ist es eben so, dass einige Firmen, wenn sie nicht gezwungen werden, ihre Sachen zu fixen, dann tun sie es nicht.
Das ist schlicht eine wirtschaftliche Sache. Das ist einfach teuer. Also man kann das klassische Beispiel auch Microsoft nennen.
Es gibt Zahlen von Microsoft, dass die, wenn sie einen Critical Bug haben, also ein Problem, mit dem man ein Wurm schreiben könnte, dann müssen sie den fixen. Und der Fix wird dann über ihr Windows-Update verteilt. Und es gibt also eine interne Qualitätssicherung, die kostet immens Geld. Und das kostet, ich habe jetzt die genauen Zahlen vergessen, ich glaube, 400.000 Dollar für so einen Fix.
Auf jeden Fall, jeder einzelne ist richtig teuer.
Pro Bug. Also natürlich lohnt sich das für Microsoft, wenn sie die Bugs selber finden. Und dann müssen sie keine Patches machen, sondern können es einfach am nächsten Service Pack mit beerdigen. Ja, aber solange keiner weiß, dass es ein Problem ist, sind Hersteller wirtschaftlich daran interessiert, das Problem nicht zu beheben.
Verstehe, weil sie ansonsten, also entweder sie machen es einfach in ihrer Routine und dann ist das sowieso, steht das sowieso auf dem Zettel und kostet Geld. Wenn aber jetzt Fefe kommt und sagt, ihr habt da ein Problem, dann müsste Microsoft darauf reagieren.
Das erhöht einfach die Priorität in der Liste. Man muss sich überlegen, gerade bei großen komplexen Softwareprojekten sind einfach eine ganze Menge Sicherheitslücken. Irgendwie müssen die Hersteller aufgrund des Ressourcenmangels, die haben ja auch nicht eine Million Leute, die da eben Sicherheitslöcher fixen, die müssen priorisieren. Und wenn es einen Exploit gibt, dann ist das mal ganz oben auf der Prioritätenliste. Das ist ein großer Unterschied.
Also wir haben jetzt in den letzten 1 oder 3 Viertelstunden mit vielen verschiedenen unterschiedlichen Beispielen versucht, darzulegen und zu erklären mit euch gemeinsam, warum dieser neue Zusatz zum Hackerparagraphen relativ unsinnig ist und warum alle, die sich damit beschäftigen, von selbst bis zum BSI, warum die alle sagen, dieses Ding ist in der Praxis nicht umsetzbar, trotzdem gibt es dieses Gesetz. Es gibt ja die Diskussion, ob dieses Gesetz wieder abgeschafft wird. Die Frage, die Johann auch stellt, der uns angerufen hat, was passiert denn, wenn dieses Gesetz wieder fällt? Guten Abend, Jonas. Johann.
Hallo. Ja, genau das ist auch meine Frage, was passiert, wenn das Gesetz gekippt wird, wie sieht das für den Endanwender aus? Es kommt ja auch darauf an, wie das Gesetz geändert wird. Es kann ja sein, dass es für Firmen Ausnahmen gibt. Nur ich bin ja auch als Endanwender gespannt, was passiert. Ich will mein eigenes Netzwerk auch sicher halten.
Ja, das wissen wir natürlich auch nicht.
Eigentlich haben wir schon eine klare Ansicht dazu, denn wir stellen uns einfach mal vor, der 202c wird ersatzlos gestrichen. Das heißt A und B bleiben, also abfangen und ausspielen von Daten, und C wird gestrichen. Also wir haben ja lange darüber diskutiert und unsere Ansicht ist eigentlich, es würde genau nichts für den Endanwender passieren, denn alles, was wirklich kriminell ist, war vorher schon und wäre dann auch noch strafbar. Und im Gegenteil, all die negativen Effekte, über die wir heute gesprochen werden, würden halt hinfällig sein. Insofern wäre das nur gut für uns alle, wenn der mal schlicht gestrichen würde.
Was wir halt nicht wissen, ist, ob der wirklich gestrichen wird. Denn das Verfassungsgericht macht es eigentlich nie oder sehr, sehr selten, dass sie sagen, das Gesetz kommt komplett in die Tonne, sondern die sagen eher, das müsst ihr nochmal überarbeiten und hier sind noch ein paar Sachen.
Dann gibt es Veränderungen.
Genau, dann gibt es ein paar kosmetische Veränderungen. Genau. Also nee, sie patchen es ja nicht selber, sondern sie sagen dir, du musst nochmal patchen. Also ja, das ist, was wir hoffen. Die Frage ist nur, wie viel sie bemängeln werden.
Ja, also nach dem Fragenkatalog, den der CCC ja bekommen hat, wir kriegen ja immer so eine Liste vom Gericht, wozu wir uns besonders äußern sollen, also da sind natürlich einige Knackpunkte klar geworden. Mehrere Fragen bezogen sich auf den Zweck der Software. Also wie man etwa mal ganz theoretisch oder zumindest nicht nur an einem praktischen Beispiel, sondern eben über eine Klasse von Programmen sagen kann, ob sie schlecht in dem Sinne sind oder eben gut. Und da haben wir uns natürlich dazu geäußert, denn wir sind tatsächlich zu der Ansicht gelangt, dass man das so pauschal über ein Programm nicht sagen kann, sondern dass am Ende natürlich der Benutzer darüber bestimmt, was der Zweck der Software ist. Denn man muss sich vorhin überlegen, wäre es so, dass man diesen Zweck bestimmen könnte, hätte man glaube ich auch eine andere Form von IT-Sicherheitsforschung heute. Also könnte man das von vornherein anhand technischer Merkmale festmachen, hätten wir sicherlich auch Schadprogramm-Detektoren, die solche typischen Programme einfach filtern würden. Also so wie es nicht die ultimative Schad-Software-Abwehr gibt, gibt es natürlich auch nicht die Programme, die immer nur Schaden anrichten. Das ist glaube ich ein ziemlich, naja, vielleicht auf einer Metaebene eine Weisheit, aber das gibt es halt in der Informationstheoretik nicht wirklich. Der Zweck der Software kann so nicht bestimmt werden.
Auch in der Praxis sieht man das. Wenn es nämlich bestimmbar wäre, dann bräuchte man keine Updates für die Anti-Viren-Signaturen. Ganz plump. Wir haben noch ein Totschlag-Argument, was wir uns bis zum Ende aufgehoben haben. Und zwar für die Leute, die sich noch nicht betroffen fühlen. Der CCC hat unter anderem in Hamburg eine Aktion gehabt, wo die Stadt Hamburg überlegt hat, ob sie nicht mit dem Wahlstift wählen sollen. Und das ist eine Art Wahlmaschine, allerdings nicht in dem Sinne, oder Wahlcomputer ist allerdings nicht in dem Sinne, wie so eine Slotmaschine, sondern das ist so ein Stift mit einer eingebauten Kamera und einem Spezialpapier mit Muster drauf. Und der Stift kann über die Kamera sehen, welches Muster da gerade ist und kann daraus erkennen, an welcher Stelle auf dem Papier man gerade ist. Das ist die Idee. Und damit wollten die ihre Wahlzettel machen und der CCC hat sich das angesehen. Wir haben uns das angeguckt und haben das gebrochen, das System. Wir haben also ein Wahlzettel gemacht unter anderem, wo eben dieses Muster verschoben war, sodass, egal wo man angekreuzt hat, immer dieselbe Partei gekriegt hat. Also das war quasi die große Präsentation. Jedenfalls haben wir unter anderem auf unserer Webseite geschrieben, wir hätten das System gehackt. Die Stadt Hamburg hat inzwischen auch gesagt, sie wollen den Wahlstift nicht mehr einsetzen. Es geht hier also der Kampf um Demokratie in diesem Lande. Und was jetzt gerade passiert, ist, dass die Herstellerfirma, also gar nicht mal der Hersteller, sondern der Reseller, die eigentliche Hardware kommt, wohl von jemand anderem?
Also die sind eine Arbeitsgemeinschaft, die teilweise eben Teile der Software herstellt.
Also die Software haben die auf jeden Fall gemacht, aber wir haben den Stift, den gibt es auch von Logitech oder so.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also sie haben sich eine Hardware, die man auch sonst kaufen kann.
Jedenfalls die Firma, die das verkauft hat, die versucht uns gerade zu verklagen mit der Begründung, weil ihr es gehackt habt. Genau. Und die Frage ist, wie sollen wir denn jetzt nachweisen, dass wir es gehackt haben, wenn das Besitzen oder das zur Verfügung stellen, zum Beispiel dem Gericht von einem Exploit, der das beweisen würde, verboten ist nach dem Hackertool-Gesetz. Das heißt, die Grundfesten unserer Demokratie, um das hier mal ein bisschen pathetisch zu sagen, sind in Gefahr durch den Hackertool-Paragraph.
Na ja, nicht wirklich, weil der Wahrschrift ist ja nur schon, hat sich eigentlich schon erledigt. Also im System der Medien ist es halt ein weniges Beispiel.
Die Art und Weise der Argumentationen ist in dem Fall natürlich deutlich.
So ähnlich wie bei dem verhinzierten Myfair-Problem. Also es versuchen einfach die Hersteller dann auch Leute, die sich mit der Sicherheit befassen, Mundtot zu machen mit ihren Rechtsabteilungen. Also da ist natürlich ein großes Problem.
Und da sieht man mal auch einen Exploit für ein Wahlgerät, was eigentlich ja natürlich einen Schaden erzeugt, also ganz offensichtlich von diesem Gesetz, nicht nur betroffen, sondern gemeint ist, kann auch was Gutes sein. Und zwar für die gesamte Demokratie in diesem Lande.
Johan, ich hoffe deine Frage ist damit erst mal beantwortet.
Wir sind etwas weit abgekommen.
Gibt es eigentlich jetzt noch eine meta-theoretische Frage so Richtung Ende der Sendung. Gibt es eigentlich einen Unterschied, wenn man sagt, Forschung mit Medizin und Forschung mit Technik wird unterschiedlich behandelt, weil dieses Argument, das das Robert-Koch-Institut natürlich irgendwelche gefährlichen Viren und Krankheitserreger hat, die sie untersuchen müssen, da kommt ja auch keiner und sagt, das dürft ihr eigentlich nicht machen.
Na doch, also da gibt es schon Regelungen. Ich darf nicht einfach einen Biokampfstoff zu Hause haben.
Ja, das ist klar.
Oder andere Gefahrstoffe. Da gibt es schon spezielle Regelungen.
Aber niemand fährt da dem Robert-Koch-Institut an die Karre, weil die müssen ja daran forschen.
Genau, also man könnte jetzt, das ist auch eine Sache, die möglicherweise das Verfassungsgericht jetzt sagen könnte, dass sie sagen, wir brauchen für Forschung und Lehre eine Ausnahme oder wir brauchen so eine Art Gefahren gut für Software. Ich hoffe, dass es dazu nicht kommt, genau aus dem Grund, den ich vorhin ausgeführt habe, selbst die Software, die völlig klar gemeint und betroffen ist von dem Gesetz, kann trotzdem gut sein. Also es gibt auch außerhalb von Forschung und Lehre, also auch diese, bei der Wahl kann man ja nicht wirklich von Forschung und Lehre reden, also man kann es konstruieren, aber im Grunde ist es ja nicht Forschung und Lehre, sondern es ist eher der Beweis, dass dieses System unsicher ist. Also uns ging es ja nicht darum, das System zu erforschen, sondern wir wollten zeigen, es ist unsicher.
Wann entscheidet denn das Bundesverfassungsgericht über diesen Paragraphen?
Auch das ist natürlich unklar. Also wir haben jetzt erst vor kurzem die Stellungnahme öffentlich gemacht und kurz vorher dann beim Gericht auch eingeschickt. Es sind noch andere Sachverständige, die dazu Stellung nehmen, also zwei weitere, ist natürlich nicht klar. Wir hoffen natürlich, es schnell geht. Es ist natürlich in der Praxis so, dass jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel passiert ist. Wir sehen natürlich jetzt schon die Auswirkungen so langsam, aber dadurch, dass es noch kein Urteil gibt, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Gefahr im Verzug.
Aber es hat mir vorhin auch schon beleuchtet, es gibt keinen Urteil, weil das Gesetz sehr schwammig ist, sondern es gibt ein schwammiges Gesetz, weil es keine weiteren Urteile gibt, wo man es festnageln könnte. Also es dreht sich einfach im Kreis.
Ja, solange die Leute nicht in den Knast kommen wegen dem Gesetz, ist mir das ehrlich gesagt recht. Im Moment, ich finde, wir geben denen jetzt ein bisschen Zeit. Das ist auch viel zu warm gerade für so eine behandelnde Urteile, die sollen immer über Raucher entscheiden. Genau. Gebt denen ein bisschen Zeit und Hauptsache Ende gut, alles gut, ist meine Einstellung dazu. Gut.
Das waren etwa zwei Stunden, knapp zwei Stunden Chaosradio. Zum Thema Hackerparagraph. Falls ihr zwischendurch reingeschaltet habt und gesagt habt, ich würde gerne die ganze Sendung hören, das geht natürlich. Die gibt es als Podcast. Einfach entweder fritz.de klicken oder aber ccc.de. chaosradio.ccc.de Man darf immer chaosradio.ccc.de klicken. Man kann auch ccc.de klicken und weiterklicken. Bei ccc.de steht ja auch noch mehr.
Aber eben, denn da muss man sowieso hinklicken, weil jetzt hat man eine Belunte gerochen und will unbedingt die Stellungnahme mal am Ganzen lesen. Das kann man tun.
Nichts ist spannender als Gesetzestexte kurz vor dem Schlafengehen.
Das ist kein Gesetzestext.
Nein, also wir haben versucht, unsere Stellungnahme nicht einschläfernd zu machen und sie ist auch so kurz, wie es irgendwie ging.
Das kann man noch mal eben lesen. Also, das liest sich ganz schnell.
chaosradio.ccc.de oder aber ccc.de oder aber fritz.de oder aber blog.fifel.de gibt es noch.
Ein winziges Detail noch. Der Kongress findet dieses Jahr wieder statt und der Call for Papers ist gerade veröffentlicht worden. Also, wenn einer von uns sich berufen fühlt, beim CCC-Kongress nicht nur als Besucher, sondern auch als Redner aufzutreten, dann könnt ihr gerne...
Wenn wir zum Beispiel fähigen Juristen, der sich gerne vor den Hackern mal so richtig tiefschürfende Gedanken, juristischer Art, über den Hackerparagraphen machen will. Und wenn man übrigens zu chaosradio.ccc.de geklickt hat, dann kann man ja auch mal nach Chaosradio Express klicken. Wir haben nämlich neben dieser Radiosendung auch immer noch den Podcast. Der ist ein bisschen geekiger, aber Tim produziert da eine große Menge an sehr interessanten Themen. Es lohnt sich immer, da hinzuklicken.
So, mehr Werbung müssen wir jetzt nicht machen. Wir wünschen euch einen großartigen Juli. Wir hören uns in vier Wochen wieder. Der Juli ist noch nicht vorbei.
Ja, aber der Ausdruck kommt eine Woche früher.
Chaosradio kommt nämlich im August eine Woche früher, weil die Games Convention schon stattfindet und die Gamechecker gesagt haben, wir müssen auf jeden Fall nach der Games Convention eine Sendung machen. Deswegen ziehen wir eine Woche vor. Ich glaube, es ist der 20. oder so. Fritz.de klicken, da steht alles drauf. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit Maxwell Smart und dem Night Flight. Der hat Milliarden Gäste da draußen rumzuliegen, die alle irgendwelche Platten mitbringen. Das wird sehr, sehr abgefahren. Fefel, Konz und Jakob sagen Tschüss, war schön gewesen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.